and minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and Ryan Nicodemus is out on assignment
today that assignment is vacation in
Montana so I have I have two guys here
with me listen last few years I've I've
had quite a few health problems
I'm turning 37 this week and two years
ago on my birthday was sort of this this
nadir of of health problems and in fact
I had so many problems I had to write
them down so that I could remember how
many health problems I had
I've got Christopher Kelly with me and
dr. Tommy woods and we're gonna talk
they're both from a company called
nourish balanced thrive and they've
helped me out immensely over the last
two years with with a lot of these
health problems I've had so Chris I
reached out to you
it was literally on my birthday when we
talked about if you know this but it was
my 35th birthday yeah and I'm just gonna
paint the picture for everyone I I've
had two mints back pain since I was a
teen I broke my l5 and eventually fused
to my s1 in fact whenever I get like I
forgot an MRI or cat scan doctors like
oh you must have had a surgery to have
that fused and no they just sort of grew
together and I couldn't sit down for
like six months when I was a freshman in
high school because of that in Ohio
where I grew up we were playing ice
basketball one day and someone tackled
me during ice basketball and ever since
then I've had some back issues and and
it really it was under control
throughout most of my 20s and then in my
30s it started to get more and more
pronounced than the pain was really bad
the beginning of 2016 January 2016 I was
waking up with 10 out of 10 horrible
like sciatica and just the pain was
unbearable like so unbearable I was like
how am I gonna get through this next
second and so I started to see different
doctors and I I saw a surgeon and I was
two weeks out from having surgery and
then but but
that I found out about this type of
physical therapy that I started doing
it's called a gas Q therapy and I'm sure
we can talk about that if necessary but
that helped out a little bit with the
back pain but I suspected something else
was wrong like maybe there was some
hormonal imbalance or or something
because I wasn't sort of recovering the
way that I should like I was doing two
hours of physical therapy every day but
it wasn't really taking like it should
and on top of that when I was about age
27 I started developing these weird
allergies like seasonal allergies but
also chemical sensitivities to I moved
into this apartment and all of a sudden
it was right after my divorce and I I
thought maybe I'm just depressed but I
didn't really see the correlation right
away I would go into a I'd go home and I
start feeling these weird symptoms my
throat would get sore and my eyes would
get watery I started to have this really
weak pathetic call just and and I
thought oh maybe I'm depressed and I
went to a doctor and I said oh yeah well
you just your mom died your marriage and
you're probably depressed right now and
I went to another doctor he's like oh no
no it's not depression it's asthma
here's an inhaler have a good day and I
saw several doctors I couldn't really
figure out and then I moved and those
symptoms got better all of a sudden I
moved into a place that I didn't have a
chemical sensitivity to and then I kind
of ignored the symptoms because they
weren't bad enough that I they weren't
causing enough pain that I was willing
to make some radical changes in my life
but then around age 34 and 35 it all
started to come crashing down and moved
into this apartment in Montana and I was
so allergic to it for lack of a better
word so sensitive it had just refinished
the floors they just painted the walls
and I felt like I couldn't breathe in
there I had to move out like emergency
level couldn't couldn't stand it anymore
and I started to feel helpless I started
to feel this type of despair there was
this sensitivity there but then I was
having all these gut problems at the
same time like
it was hard for me to digest anything
like wheat or just carbohydrates in
general like anytime I would eat fiber I
had the worst work kind of gas and it
was it was terrible but then around the
summer of 2016 I started getting like
brain fog and then I got this temporary
memory loss
like I short-term memories were just
gone and I couldn't and then I started
to not be able to remember basic words
like I would look at the table but I
wouldn't remember that it was called a
table like what's the name was Brian and
this thing it was so frightening and and
and then like my hormones were all out
of whack like I'm in the best
relationship I've ever been in Rebecca
My partner is amazing she's so
supportive and we're gonna actually talk
a little bit about that today having
supportive people when we're going
through these health problems in fact
she's made it so much easier for me to
get through a lot of these health
problems but she's been so supportive
and I'm in this great relationship with
a person I'm so attracted to but my
libido was through the floor summer of
2016 not only was my libido through
before but I I had problems with
erectile dysfunction and so I'm like
okay wait a minute
I've got terrible back pain horrible
back pain I've got brain fog I can't
remember stuff I can't digest things I
can't be around paint or any sort of
chemicals without having all these
terrible allergies I had horrible
seasonal allergies and that got to a
point and probably my hormones are so
out of whack that I'm not even attracted
to the person I'm attracted to I'm not
attracted to anyone I have no desire to
have sex or anything like what the hell
is going on with me and then I got
desperate and so where do you go and you
get desperate Google and I I stumbled
across this this website for this
company called nourish balance thrive it
was actually you did a podcast of the
guy named Ben Greenfield oh yeah I
didn't die I had no idea Ben Greenfield
was I really I had no idea who you were
but thanks to Google what connected me
to the Ben green Phil podcast
and then you were talking about many of
the things that were going on with me
and I realized like wow maybe maybe
there's some sort of solution now
obviously I wanted a magic pill I wanted
a I wanted to call Chris up and say hey
give me a prescription to fix this
immediately and I remember talking to
you on my 35th birthday
and the thing that you said to me he
said hey it's gonna be okay
I I can't tell you like how relieving
that was I know it was like the
strangest sort of like it's weird that I
needed permission for to realize like oh
maybe this is going to be okay because
to be honest with you that summer I
really thought I was dying like I
thought this was the slow descent
towards death I mean when you start
losing your memory hmm all of a sudden
you're like oh I mean I got my will and
order and I I'm I was preparing to like
oh this this might be the end of it all
and I talked to you on the phone and you
said hey we've got a program I could try
to work with you we can do some testing
and we could talk about some of these
problems and you started talking to me
about really basic things like sleep and
hormones and diet and exercise and and
these were all things that I knew like
fundamentally but like we started
getting into the more granular things
that would be more applicable for me
like we all know the diet and exercise
and sleep are important and I had a
pretty good diet and exercise regimen
and and I had what I thought was a
decent sleep regimen that actually
wasn't but it is now thankfully and over
the last two years we have slowly worked
together to try to get to the bottom of
what these health problems are and the
weird thing is even though it's all in
one body I'm all one person I didn't
realize how interconnected all of these
problems are like it's almost like I
treated them as if they were standing in
separate corners of the room right right
and so Chris when I called you and we we
started talking about hey this is going
to be okay
what were your first thoughts when I
started telling you about about some of
these issues I was dealing with
well the story resonated I mean this is
that reason I started the business right
yeah you always wonder I mean that's so
that's why I did I went on to the Ben
Greenfield podcast and told a story
similar to yours we're thinking am I
completely bonkers am I the only person
this has ever happened to ya and then
you know several hundred people come
forward and say that's exactly what
happened to me can you send me all of
the things that you did I want the diet
I want the tests I want the supplements
I want everything you did in a package
that I can buy here's my credit card
number and you know but when we do that
we're also sort of looking but again I I
did I knew I wanted the the immediate
result but I knew that that wasn't
possible that was the first thing you
try a about - like hey it's going to
take some time there this is a process
and the thing that you've known working
with me last years I'm willing to do
whatever telling to put in the work
whatever work is required I am willing
to do that because I also understand it
isn't I'm not going to just like oh here
I'm gonna upload this program into my
brain and via osmosis all of a sudden
I'm healed and I know it doesn't work
that way
mmhmm yeah absolutely been even
extraordinary in that regard I was
thinking about that earlier today that
most people they have ambivalence you
know when I asked you to start eating
red meat because you have an iron
deficiency most people they kind of
squirm a bit and say you know what I
really like not eating me I don't think
I'm gonna do that you know but you were
extraordinary and every time we came up
with a record I say we it's not the
Royal way so at this point it might be
an idea to introduce how this program
where it's not just me I didn't just
show up with all this information right
I'm standing on the shoulders of giants
especially Tommy and so Tommy is the
architect of our program and I think of
myself as a builder you know I show up
on site and it's not really on site it's
via zoom or the telephone in this case
sure and deliver somebody's information
but yeah usually what happens is people
have ambivalence and they don't really
want to change in it it takes some time
before they do start to implement some
of the things that we recommend but you
are extraordinary in that you just
present the evidence and then the next
time we talk it's it's done like okay
yeah I reintroduce I had everybody
yesterday it was fantastic I hadn't
treated as medicine right like so so
here's a weird thing when I was in my
mid-20s I was a vegan for a year on a
bet so I used to weigh about 80 pounds
more than I weigh now and so I was just
looking for ways to lose weight and I'd
heard about this thing this vegan diet
and I'm like oh this like it was clearly
healthier than what I was eating right
and so for a year Ryan and I both went
on this this vegan die in the corporate
world and the reason we did it is is I
just told him about it one day and he's
like what the hell is a vegan and I'm
like don't worry about a Ryan you could
never do it and that's the only thing
you ever need to tell Ryan if you can't
do something he's like well forget it
I'm gonna go research this thing and I'm
going to figure this out today he calls
me up a few hours later and he's like
alright I'm in and I bet you I can do it
longer than you and so he actually won
the bet I did it for 11 months and but
then I went back and like I lost the
taste for me and I went back to eating
fish and I ate well for the next decade
I fish once or twice a day and that
called some mercury poisoning which we
can talk about in a little bit that
Nick's with the sort of metal in my
mouth and so that was an additional
health problem that I had tacked onto to
everything else that we had just talked
about but was so when you said we did
the initial test you know like hey
you're low on iron I think you should
reintroduce meat and I'm like cringing
because like I knew it was gross to me
at the time but but also like I'm wanted
to treat it as medicine so literally I
remember that that first day I went over
to Chipotle and I literally I was like I
know I can't eat the whole portion of
meat right now right and so I said just
give me three little cubes of the steak
and they're like well I might just give
me three cubes they like I have to eat
these right now and then like I'll
slowly reintroduce this because it is
medicine and and and no I just like a
little kid I mean I've got a
five-year-old she doesn't want to take
her her medicine at night and so what do
they do they they have some sort of
sugar coating right yeah yeah and and so
for me the reward was feeling better and
I knew that I wouldn't feel better
instantly but this was what was going to
get me to go down that road and so we
went through some tests we first figured
out I had something called c-diff right
and I've aggressive unfriendly bacteria
right
and everyone has CDF to it to a certain
extent it's a I mean it's a bacteria but
can you talk a little bit about that we
might be more probably appropriate for
Tommy to talk about it but I think yes
you're right it's there in everybody's
gut
but when something goes wrong and you
lose the other key players then this bad
guy has the opportunity to overgrow do
you think that's fair Tommy Jonah yeah
that's exactly it
so when people talk about what's going
on in the gut and the bugs in the gut
the gut microbiota whatever you want to
call it there's often it's often
characterized as these are good and
these are bad but that's never the case
in medicine or biology right sadly it's
just not that simple
however when you have an imbalance so
you have too much of one versus and not
enough and other that's usually how they
come together then you're gonna you're
gonna see some issues and CDF is a
common one particularly now with the use
of antibiotics so if you take
particularly broad-spectrum antibiotics
or antibiotics that target a lot of
different bacteria then you sort of
clean out a lot of some of what's going
on in the gut and a lot most of its good
and then some of these other guys can
they grow to fill the niche that's been
left by those other bugs you've killed
with antibiotics and CDF is one
particularly particularly in hospitals
particularly in older people not that
I'm calling you old but that's that's
where we see them where we see it most
frequently and it can be
life-threatening and actually an
overgrowth of c-diff but we see a very
frequent frequently in our clients who
for various reasons there's some kind of
imbalance going on and then then it can
cause issue so that's exactly what was
happening with you yeah that's
absolutely and the thing is I for the
almost the previous decade so I had
really bad scalp acne which is probably
the best place to have acne because if
you have hair it covers it up right and
so I'm like uh it was actually a soy
allergy I didn't know that for for many
years but like if I eat some stuff like
eats a piece of tofu I get a huge
outbreak on my head right and so I
didn't realize the time and so I went to
a dermatologist and he's like yeah back
trend it's the this antibody you just
take it every single day it's benign
I'm like the doctor said the antibiotics
benign so I'm taking this antibiotic
every day for nearly a decade and it
totally destroyed my gut it was it was
right around the it was shortly before
my mother died my marriage inside these
two traumatic events I also worked in
retail and we were remodeling all of
these stores right around the same time
so I was exposed to all these crazy
chemicals that were going on so I I mean
I open dozens of retail stores and I was
there you know with the hard hats and
everything and and making sure everyone
was doing their job so I was exposed to
all these chemicals I'm doing this
intense antibiotic treatment and plus
anytime I got a cold what did I do I
went and got a z-pack or whatever and
they just take the antibiotics and
you'll be fine I totally destroyed my
guy now I write around 27 and then
beyond I just started having all these
gut issues which through through this
testing which by the way when you first
started sending me these tests it's not
like it's just one test right I mean my
my kitchen was just filled with piss and
[ __ ] and I mean it was like you've got
these little stool things and you're
peeing on things you're spitting and
vials and you're peeing on these strips
but this was important in figuring out
like and the interesting thing is I
think out of the first six or seven
tests that we did a lot of them came
back sort of I'll say inconclusive like
there's a whole lot to do with this here
and then all of a sudden we got the six
or seventh one back here like oh here's
the c-diff thing and then from there you
recommended doing some stuff with
supplementation and with my diet that
would change that and I remember talking
about leaky gut as well is that
something that we should talk about at
this point sure all right let's do it
yes important problem so it's it's
actually a really interesting problem
because it's not really accepted in the
regular medical community and and there
are a few things that sort of exists in
the fringe health sphere which we
occasionally inhabit but I want to be
really clear that the reason I was so
attracted to what you guys were talking
about is it you you you may have like
you dip a toe into the eastern world but
only if there's like like evidence
exactly it's not just like well here
yeah just if first call Chris would've
been like yeah just rubbed this crystal
against your face three times a day like
even as desperate as I was for answers I
think I would have said yeah thank you
very much have a nice day
the next phase so you're right one of
the benefits of not being in a rigid
formalized medical system which we're
not is that you can you can change and
adapt and adopt things as they become
more evidence-based and that's something
you know leaky gut is certainly one of
those things some people might call it
intestinal permeability and there's
plenty of evidence to show that people
with various autoimmune diseases even
metabolic diseases type 2 diabetes if
you take a piece of their guts and you
look at it there's for want of a better
word there's holes in it there's meant
to be connections between the cells and
the guts that stop things that you don't
want coming across coming across and
there are many things that can can
affect that and it can be foods you're
intolerant to it could be certain toxic
things that you're exposed to
one thing that c-diff does is it makes a
toxin which breaks down or you know
causes some of those junctions to be
broken down so that results in a leaky
gut or some degree of intestinal
permeability and then what happens is
either things that new parts of the
bacteria so bacteria they're there they
do good stuff for us but they do also
contain some things that can be toxic
those have easier access to your body
other things that you're eating that
maybe you don't want to get into your
bloodstream until you've fully digested
them they're getting across early that
can also cause issues so whatever the
initial cause is and there can be many
then all of a sudden you have this whole
host of symptoms and this is one of
those things where you're talking about
how the whole body is connected and
often it's at least part of that is
connected through the guts as something
that we see certainly very frequently in
our in our clients the people that we
work with and this is one of the
downsides of
the way modern medicine is structured
which is that everybody separated by a
body part right so you have a
neurologist who only looks at your brain
and you have a hepatologist or who only
looks at your liver and you know you
have an ophthalmologist so let me look
at your eyes except for the fact that
all of these things are connected by a
blood stream and all these other things
that are happening in the body at the
same time the hormone signaling covers
the whole body so when we sort of
separate our body parts we don't look at
the big picture as often I think that's
where that's where we hopefully can can
start to piece things together and and
often as was the case with you it sort
of can stem with some kind of large
exposure or something that's going on
inside inside the guts well I think that
that's one of the big problems because
when I went to doctors and they said
here's an inhaler or you're just
depressed and let me prescribe some nor
dil or something and I I'm against sort
of antidepressants unless I think
they're absolutely necessary I think we
suffer from a lot of sadness and we
often categorized it as depression and
we try to just give someone the medicine
when there's a whole bunch of other like
sort of real medicine that will will
work better like exercise in sunlight
and water right people use try these
things as well but I remember going to a
GI doctor who's like just the because my
in my early 30s as my gut problems got
worse I'm like having a GI doctor and
he's like yeah it just takes a Metamucil
for the rest of your life and you'll be
fine and I mean that's the other main
reason I started the business was as an
engineer I recognized that there was
absolutely zero attempts to see what was
going wrong there was no root cause
analysis like it's obviously a complex
system and I can see that you've spent
exactly zero minutes trying to figure
out what's causing this problem so for
the example of your scalp acne they
didn't spend a lot of time trying to
investigate whether or not was a food
sensitivity that was causing that
problem I'm just gonna jump straight to
a solution I just happened to have right
here in my desk drawer yeah right and of
course this does doesn't work it doesn't
work in health it doesn't work anywhere
else either so for example when I'm
riding a bicycle and I get a flat tire
if I just shove another tube in there
and pump it up the chances are it's
going to go flat again because the thorn
is still stuck in the
or whatever punctured the tube is still
there you have to find out why the tire
went flat before you put a new tube in
and for some reason in medicine they
don't do that they just jumped straight
to the to the solution which in my
opinion doesn't work right right and and
because often the solution is is
figuring out what the problem actually
is right and and and for me it was okay
I'm having these gut problems but it's
not just like all of a sudden your guts
gone bad it's that there's something
that's underlying it and one was like
hey no more antibiotics unless
absolutely necessary and don't get me
wrong I'm not an anti I'm not an anti
antibiotic guy what's it aunt antibiotic
a biotic guy but I'm I'm all for them
when appropriate right it's just we've
been using them inappropriately in fact
one of the words I use when people we
talk about minimalism and that word
scares people then I say okay just use
the word appropriate like maybe it's
appropriate ISM like because what's
appropriate for your life may not be
appropriate for mine with respect to the
material possessions that we own and by
the way when I first found minimalism I
was 28 years old and I'll be 37 this
week so almost a decade later what was
appropriate then is it appropriate now
I've got a five-year-old daughter like
my life is different and it's it's true
with each of our our our diets and our
health I think there are some
overarching principles that make a lot
of sense but then what really helped me
is when we chatted you got down to the
granular level and we said okay here are
some tests that are appropriate and
we'll try these in fact you even waited
on the heavy metals test because when I
had this this leaky guy you like I can't
even we can't even address heavy metals
until we address
the leaky gut thing so why was that yes
and we've seen a lot of people get worse
I mean Tommy you might be able to talk
to some of the more specific technical
details but if you've got increased
intestinal permeability aka leaky gut
and also heavy metal toxicity and you
try and pull those metals out of where
they're safely in storage then the gut
is an important part of that
detoxification process and we've
definitely I've known several people
that have gotten much worse you know you
go to another problem medicine is that
people tend to specialize and then wood
whatever problem you go to them with oh
this is definitely heavy metal problem
I've seen this thousands of times for
it's a heavy metal
we're just going to go straight into IV
chelation therapy and it's going to fix
you because every problem is a
heavy-metal problem it's like you give a
man once did the back surgery I was two
weeks away from that and of course I
went to a surgeon he recommended surgery
right he didn't recommend chakra
alignment right surprise surprise yeah
and the sad thing is and he was a great
guy in fact I really liked him but but
he all he had to do is recommend this
thing called a gas Q therapy there at
least tried this alley there there's
some sort of physical therapy that you
can do for me it was a it's a I still do
it I did it this morning I do for 45
minutes every every single day because I
have that messed up vertebrae and there
was like 25 of gas Q clinics across the
country I've seen other people there I
don't get any endorsement from them
whatsoever just like you guys I pay you
guys a fee every month I'm that there's
no no one pays me to to talk about these
things but these are things that have
really helped me and and the the the
physical therapy was something that
wasn't free but it's damn near free and
I don't have it's not invasive at all in
fact it makes me stronger as well you
know it's it's strengthened the the
muscles that were otherwise neglected
for most of my life because I spent 8 to
12 hours a day seated at a desk just
typing away right and it made me realize
that the lifestyle that I was leading
was ostensibly healthy but but it wasn't
it certainly wasn't optimized for health
and just because it wasn't unhealthy
doesn't mean that it was also healthy
and and I think that's that's kind of
where we are right now we're becoming
more and more aware of health like no
one thinks it's a good idea to smoke
anymore even people who are smoking
every day don't think it's a good idea
and I don't think it's not a problem but
but there's also the the sitting every
day the excess amount of sugars refined
refined carbs that we're eating like all
this garbage that we're putting into our
bodies the the seating the lack of the
seated miss the lack of sleep we're
experiencing all of these sort of low
level amounts of unhealth for lack of a
better term and
what happens is you turn 35 like I did
and it is all culminated at this right a
life that I thought was relatively
healthy all of a sudden came cascading
down yeah did you get a glimpse of your
mortality as well that was the one thing
that motivated me you realized that it's
quite stoic isn't it remember you will
die yeah like you kind of like I'm not
getting any younger and this is not
going any better and I say I joke that I
don't want to work with anyone that's
younger than 35 because I feel like you
have to have that glimpse of your
mortality before your you'll do all the
things that we asked you to do what is
this weird thing where I was at somewhat
at peace with that but I also knew I
didn't want to die and if I was going to
die I didn't want to be in pain and
suffering in the process right and by
the way like I shouldn't be thinking
about this at 35 of oh crap I really
feel like this is it this is the path
I'm going down and it's terrifying to me
let's fix it and if if I don't want to
go down that path and I'm willing to do
anything to change that now I really
think that's that's the inside if I
could give that to anyone who's
listening to this is you have to be
willing to actually make the change yeah
it's important to work with people who
are experts and not find the crystal
healer who is going to sell you a bunch
of lies but find people who are going to
be your advocates and be supportive of
you in that process so you all work with
with a lot of people many of whom are
athletes but a bunch of different folks
and it seems to me that you found some
significant commonalities and are the
commonalities and symptoms or problems
or one of the one of a lot of the
commonalities you deal with now so I
think where we started is is with Chris
who had his his issues as as an athlete
particularly and then all all the things
that you described so issues with gut
health erectile dysfunction well always
associated brain fog and then so I think
initially the business was founded on
people in so endurance athletes with
those kinds of symptoms and actually you
find that if you're if you train the way
you're told to train for endurance
events so this could be mountain biking
or cycling or triathlon which is
basically quite attritional it's
go out and crush yourself as hard as you
can as often as you can every day and
then in order to recover from that you
just have to eat a whole load of refined
carbohydrates Gatorade cereal pasta
bread make sugar packs yeah cycle is
used to be a dealer of that stuff I had
the wholesale account and I had my bike
team and I was the dealer you know I was
the one that put in the group order and
then everybody got the wholesale price
that used to get back from every bike
ride with this sticky ball of these
wrappers of this stuff and I'd use one
of those every 40 minutes and I
absolutely had to have it else I'd start
to have some sort of hypoglycemic
episode or what I felt like one you know
II like dizzy and really hungry ya know
it's ugly yeah and when you do and when
you do that so there are some people who
thrive in that environment and they do
great and you know that's fine but it's
a small percentage of the population and
everybody else ends up broken in some
way or another so I think that that's
sort of been a core of our of our
clientele often endurance athletes lots
of triathletes some runners but then as
the more we talk about this and the more
we look into you know hormones and the
guts so we have a lot of people who have
got issues that's just what we talk
about a lot and that's who we seem to
attract in terms of in terms of the
people that work with us know when you
say talk about you guys have a podcast
nourish balance thrive podcast well
we'll put a link to that Sean podcast
Sean if you put that the show notes as
well but what the thing I like about is
you touch on these different topics so I
don't have to listen to every episode
but there are ones that like it's always
download each one and then it's in my
feed and I'm like oh hey I really want
to hear that one or oh that one's
intrigued you know I never even thought
about that and so you have these these
topics where I can dive a little bit
deeper and I feel like I get more than I
would for out of a TED talk but I also
don't feel like I don't have to read a
medical textbook in order to understand
it so thank you for your podcast I
appreciate that well sometimes you have
to read a medical textbook if I get if I
get really into it then then sometimes
they'll make people's eyes go crossed
but I try not to do that too frequently
but yes so so basically now where we're
at is we work with anybody who has a
performance goal and you might think of
performance
in terms of athletics I want to run
under three hours in a marathon right
that would be an athletic performance
goal but for some people it might be I
have a five-year-old daughter I want to
be able to play with her yeah I want to
have the energy to to spend time with my
kids or I want to actually be able to
function at my desk for my job that
could be a performance goal so because I
came to you and I wasn't an athlete at
all I was wondering like I wonder if
these guys would even talk to me right
and and I realized that the yes
performance can mean athletic
performance but it could just mean like
getting better so you can be your best
self right it's just a function the
optimizing for it could be anything yeah
yeah and so the hormone thing was
something that was important because my
hormones were all out of whack I had my
I remember my human growth hormone was
relatively low at the time and I think
that's why a lot of the I was doing
physical therapy every day but it wasn't
really sticking because like I wasn't
building up the the musculature and when
we started fixing some of the gut stuff
and and through supplementation I feel
like eventually it all started clicking
and and and that that back pain and went
from a 10 to a 7 when I started doing
physical therapy is now at roughly a 1
or 0
most days this amazing it's it's
essentially gone and I'm stronger than I
ever was and it's really simple sort of
stuff but I don't think that would have
happened had my hormones stayed out of
whack the whole time and then of course
my libido was through the floor and now
Bex has to fight me off every day it's I
mean it that I can tell you the the the
true is sort of test here that there
isn't I mean we can do the blood tests
or whatever like that stuff's great we
were just talking about this last week I
think the true test is is how you feel
you need these these markers to help
understand there's nothing was radically
wrong with you but but for me it's like
my sex drive is through the roof I feel
way better than I did two years ago I
feel like I feel like you know to use a
sports analogy I started off with sort
of the one-yard line and I was getting
ready to get sacked for a safety like
like it was not going to be good I don't
know if this translates I don't have any
cricket analogies I'm sorry Joe you
played for five days and there's the
draw the same analogy so I felt like I
was at the one-yard line and and and the
thing I want to stress is I'm not a
hundred percent there I feel like I'm 80
yards down the field which is a
significant improvement from where I was
two years ago
and if you were to go back to my my 35
year old self and say hey if you put in
an immense amount of work you're gonna
get eighty percent better over the next
two years I'm gonna said hell yes yes
like whatever I can do to get there also
realizing I'm still headed in the right
direction and the changes from here are
gonna be especially incremental because
to get that last 20% is I figuring out
what is this sort of edge case is one of
the slight tweaks that I need to make
because I've made all the dramatic
tweaks and I've made a bunch of other
small tweaks along the way as well and
so I still feel like I'm you know 80% of
the way there I still have some chemical
sensitivities they're considerably less
than than what they were but I was at
podcast Shawn's new apartment yesterday
and he just had a remodel and I walked
in there within half an hour I started
getting a little sore throat and little
runny nose and I'm like okay like III
realize I still have some chemical
sensitivities right and I still have
some tiredness that that I will
experience especially in the afternoons
even though I have a relatively low
carbohydrate diet and like I'm eating
you know three bowls of rice for lunch
and then crashing like III do get more
tired than say my 31 year old self did
and I bring my 31 year old self oh
because that to me that felt like the
sort of peak health for me even though
there was a lot of stuff going starting
to go wrong it's what felt like the most
sort of I was the most physically fit
but also like maybe most mentally sharp
as well and I feel him getting really
close to that and what's exciting to me
is to get back to that and then surpass
it I feel like I can do that I feel like
I'm maybe a year or two years away from
really surpassing that and by the time I
hit age 4
I'll be sharper and fitter than I was at
30 and certainly then I was at 25
because I was fat and unhealthy at 25 I
was working 80 hours a week and sleeping
literally three or four hours a night
every night and I didn't realize how
unsustainable that was one of the things
that you did help me adjust quite a bit
was my my sleep and I had built up this
weird pattern that was starting I
thought to work for me I would sleep
three hours a night two nights in a row
and I would sleep nine hours on the
third night I don't know why that worked
for me at the time but eventually it
stopped working and I realized that
there was just a lot of small
adjustments that I needed to make with
screens and getting sunlight in the
morning can we talk about some of those
basic things that will help help out
with sleep quite a bit yeah and why why
is sleep so important and why did we
neglect it so much yeah I mean I I can
talk about some of the practical
concerns because I'm definitely living
it but Tommy's the neuroscientist but
actually should talk about why sleep is
so important and well there's both sides
of that are very important but in terms
of the practicality and then the science
but the so essentially sleep is the only
time that you have for a lot of the
tissues in the body to repair and that
goes from the brain all the way out to
the skin so there's even some really
interesting data on how light at the
wrong time on on the skin at nights when
the skin is supposed to preparing itself
that sort of predisposes you to things
like skin cancers so even like sleep and
darkness at the right time a lot you
know that's when the body repairs itself
essentially that's when the brain
flushes out all the stuff that's been
accumulating during the day as you've
been thinking and doing whatever it is
that you do during the day and in terms
of the the light exposure there's two
important parts to it so there's
sunlight during the day and which helps
time everything that happens in the body
happens on us what we call a circadian
rhythm so the jury circa dere means
roughly a day so happens at a specific
time during the day and there are
hundreds of genes and proteins and
things that your body makes in different
amounts depending on the time of day and
the way that your body knows what time
of day it is is it should be sunlight
bright light during the day and you know
right now we're inside this is this
would be nowhere near enough lights to
set a circadian rhythm even though it's
it feels bright to us compared to what
you get from sunlight it's really it's
really nothing it's a fraction and then
at night you need darkness because that
tells your body that it's nighttime but
you produce of a hormone called
melatonin which some people may have
taken to try and help them sleep because
they spend their evenings staring a
screen which suppresses their body
making melatonin so blue and green
lights particularly in the bright LEDs
that we get on screens phones and
computer screens and reel and
televisions everything that you know is
really good at suppressing our melatonin
production and melatonin so it times the
clock it sets our metabolism but it also
has some you know antioxidant effects
anti-cancer effects they're using it in
studies to try and repair injured brains
as part of cancer therapy so melatonin
has all these amazing effects yet we're
suppressing it by watching all these
screens at night and you know so the two
ways to prevent that is to make sure we
get Sun during the day which again sort
of helps prime us to make melatonin a
night and then also just avoid those
bright bright lights at night yeah yeah
I've added a few things and you and I
talked about this a little bit like a
sleep mask and and some earplugs and and
just some some really basic things but
it had more to do with I think the the
practice of getting sunlight as soon as
it's available I tend to still wake up
I'm just an early bird Soleil I still
wake up before the Sun goes up and so I
got this thing called a human charger
and I don't know what the science is
behind it you've sent me a few a few
studies on it but what are your thoughts
on on sort of art the artificial light
from that so I think that that can help
its if nothing else it certainly gives
me the placebo we you know we're big
fans of the placebo if you can get a
placebo from something that has
literally zero downsides you know that's
great if it makes you feel better than
that and it's not displacing something
better
but it's really good for jet lag in
particular so if you're trying to time
your circadian rhythm to something that
you're about to go to or somewhere where
you've just arrived you know part of
jetlag is the fact that your body has no
idea what time of day it is right and so
then the light and the day and darkness
at night is a big part of that so the
human charge has some great evidence for
that but then for the same reason if
you're not going to be exposed to bright
light then making sure that your body is
getting some of those cues at the right
time even if it's not from sunlight
I think can't kind of have a big benefit
so it makes sense yeah and I was living
in Montana at the time too so like all
winter it's dark and cloudy and and the
Sun of them come up until I swear it's
what does a show like 10:00 a.m. or
something crazy it it's still bright out
there right compared to what the the
light level of light that you experience
indoors truth get light meter Oh summer
sunrise wasn't until like 10:00 a.m. and
I think yeah I would get up at like like
4 or 5 oh wow okay and so even between
you know I'd have five hours between
sunrise even though it was cloudy yes so
you would still have brightness but it
was diffused through many many yeah yeah
I mean it's it's Canada basically and
and so I mean we're in California now so
I have a lot more Sun and I can tell you
there's been a marked difference in my
mood and Becks I mean I for whatever
reason I'm one of those people who is
ultra sensitive to light so I I walk
every day I probably walk about eight
miles a day and doing so on the Sun like
there is this marked difference and in
my overall mood and happiness and one of
the things you and I talked about is
sometimes it's just about changing your
environment and that might mean changing
the geography altogether I know you when
you move do you kind of moved out into
the middle of nowhere just I mean part
of that had to do with cycling I assume
but the other parts why why the change
in geography for you and how does that
translate to other people well actually
the main reason was to be closer to my
wife's family we had a baby and you know
it's really how I mean this is another
thing I mean all of these things they
revolve around this principle of
ancestral health like how can we
recreate
the lifestyle of the hunter-gatherer
that lived 10,000 years ago as best we
can because they seem to have been the
best humans that ever lived in you know
so being part of that strong sociability
or lying science yeah exactly yeah I
mean that's one of the storm an
arguments against the Paleo diet is you
know like these caricatures of like
reenacting being a caveman right it's
not a reenactment it's just like what
what's the best we can do given what's
available what's appropriate is a very
good word and yes so that was partly to
be closer to my wife's family but yeah I
must admit it's very nice I live in
Bonnie Doon which is just outside Santa
Cruz and I get tons of sunshine there's
Bonnie Doon manzanita trees and redwood
trees and were five minutes from the
ocean and it's beautiful and I'm you
know very grateful for the amount of
time that I can spend outdoors in nature
in the sunshine and I think my health is
benefited from it greatly yeah and
here's the weird thing I remember when
both of you recommended this like I just
finished a tour and you're like okay I
think you should take a month I live in
the woods now see you are a traffic
exactly what triathletes do pride
themselves in to the floor oh yeah it's
a it's a different type of performance
but yeah we did you know a 50 city tour
and afterward you were like hey I think
that you should go live in the woods
from what but for me that sounds like
hell like I grew up really poor and so I
don't want to recreate that with camping
we were I mean our electricity got
turned off all the time sometimes the
water would stop running that's because
we didn't pay the bill and so for me
like I actually I think going camping
would really stress me out and then we
had this conversation about this and
you're like okay well what would be the
ideal sort of relaxing environment for
me it's like it's coming to LA and just
walking around the city for a while and
and I think partner has to do with like
the psychology of the individual because
yes I I and I've by the way I've lived
in the middle of no we when we first
moved to Montana we moved to this cabin
in the middle of nowhere to write a book
we're there for four months side of a
mountain Montana winter and the only
thing you can do is write because it's
negative 26 degrees when you wake up in
the morning and and there's nothing else
to do with your time right and so I
would basically just write and so I
understand the sort of Dinah
of isolation but but for me what was
best for my psychology was finding the
right place yeah you were with your
people here I can see yeah yeah and it
was finding your own tribe and and I
think that's gonna be different for
everyone in fact I think the first seven
or eight times I came to Los Angeles I
didn't find the right people and and
there's a certain stigma to Los Angeles
and yeah if you're looking for that side
of things the self-absorbed you
egomaniac sand narcissus you're gonna
find that but guess why you'll probably
find that in Dayton Ohio too if you're
looking for it but if you fought and
there's 20 million people in Southern
California if you can't find the right
people then well I don't exactly so I
can tell you there's it has been a
marked difference in changing of
geography for me but I wanted to get
into some some questions we have from
our audience so we usually do some
voicemails but today I wanted to go
through my story instead of going
through the voicemails but I do have
some questions I reached out to our
audience on social media we usually call
this the the lightning round but cuz
Ryan and I usually answer these
questions was a short shareable less
than 140 character response well we're
not gonna do that today
beside I don't like Twitter you can you
can monitor on a bit and then maybe if
we have something really pissy that is
shareable what will will write it down
in the show notes or something for those
you want to share it we're on Instagram
and Facebook and Twitter at the
minimalist by the way I wrote this down
I want to get to it I said a social
media [ __ ] us I wanted to get like
from from a health perspective because I
I've found it to be both wildly helpful
and wildly intrusive simultaneously now
we started using social media radically
differently this year we wrote this
whole sort of mini manifesto of how
we're going to use because I thought
what we were doing up until this year is
we weren't being very intentional about
how we were using social media was like
oh I'll post a picture on Instagram and
then repost it on Twitter and then re
reposted on Facebook and it was like
those those carbon copies where he's put
sign something in triplicate I'm like
this is
literally the definition of insanity
doing the same thing over and over that
why am I doing this say why am I not
using these these platforms more
intentionally so we started using the
platform's a lot more intentionally
Instagram is really good for sharing
beautiful photos and Facebook was really
good for sharing links so that
interesting and informative articles and
Twitter is good for sharing words and so
that's how we started using these and we
provided these sort of creative
limitations that have helped us use them
better but but the question for me is
still like how useful is it a friend of
mine is a guy named Cal Newport you guys
familiar with him he wrote a book called
so good they can't ignore you also
another one called deep work yeah that's
the one oh yeah I definitely got that
name I haven't read it yeah and he has a
great TED talk called quit social media
okay and he's a professor at Georgetown
we had him on the podcast at a live
event we did in Washington DC and the
the thing that he talks about is the how
social media for most people is a net
negative and for me I think right now it
is a net positive but I don't know
whether or not I'm just tricking myself
so I'd love to know what you guys think
about it from from a health perspective
I think there's there's two parts to it
so like we mentioned earlier nothing is
good and bad right there's there's
everything is shades of grey right at
least 50 of them sorry but so on the
good side is is part of the kind of
stuff that we do so say if you have or
you know in that world say you have a
specific health problem or you have a
specific thing you're trying to do be it
a specific diet or yet some problem
you're trying to solve you can find a
group of people who have the same issues
have done it before have loads of advice
can be supportive because you might not
be able to get that same support and
knowledge from your local community
right it might just be you there just
aren't that many people around you who
have this specific autoimmune condition
or who want to try a paleo or Keith's
genic diet or go vegan right you might
not have that tribe so you can get
access to that tribe and it can be very
rewarding and very supportive so that's
one positive on the other side
particularly
with younger people we see more and more
that social media use is connected to
mental health problems and it makes
perfect sense because a it's replacing
real human connection which is
incredibly important you're spending
time with your family and your friends
in you know in real life outdoors doing
something you know doing something
beneficial to yourself or you know
somebody else and it Apes the form of
connection without really providing that
yes you know you think you're connected
I have a thousand friends look how
connected I am they're not connections
they like if you needed help from these
people how many of them are going to
give it if you needed true support how
many of them are going to gonna give it
and it's very small fraction and so you
and what at the same time you're
constantly comparing yourself right so I
was reading the other day about how you
know this is a good point where when you
were at school right so maybe school
sucked and you were bullied and but then
3:30 you go home and you don't have to
think about those kids until the next
morning now they're on Facebook they're
on Twitter you see them 24 hours a day
like cannot you just cannot escape the
bullying yeah yeah they exactly that you
cannot escape being bullied and it just
is continuous and at the same time you
see these other people who are in your
class and yeah they have all this stuff
and you know they they look happy all
the time and you know you're just it's a
constant set up for you to think of
yourself as a failure and that kind of
spiral downward so can be beneficial can
be negative and the science that's
coming out now just starting I think
because we've only just had sort of the
tip of the iceberg of the social media
boon and then the downstream effects but
you know overall again particularly for
young people really seems to be having a
net negative effect yeah and and I don't
know what the answer is yet I mean I can
say use it more deliberately I don't
know what the broader answer is but I
think the the individual answer is
assessing what our needs are and and
then what is appropriate for me and then
also building up these either
disciplines but also maybe self-imposed
constraints so we were talking about the
constraints earlier but I don't have
social media on my phone and it's not
because I believe that Instagram is
inherently evil it's because I don't
trust myself with layi
well as soon as I'm in line at Chipotle
it's the first thing I will do is like
just pull out my phone and and I'll be
one of the other 15 people who's staring
at the the screen sort of mindlessly and
not getting the value from that that I
would buy maybe just pausing and
thinking or maybe open up my Kindle app
and reading a book there are
alternatives that are our better
alternatives and without completely
leaving it behind and and being a total
Luddite I don't think that's what any of
us are prescribing either but but I
think it's about finding the the
discipline to use these things
responsibly in a way that that allows us
to get value from it and and not just
pretend we're getting value from it not
just to pacify ourselves with it talk
about the cognitive middle gear Tommy
that's a very interesting thing yes so
this is something that I guess I learned
about from a friend of mine
James Hewitt who works for a company
that I help can consult with they work
both with corporate clients and they
also do a lot of the coaching for
Formula One drivers that's kind of their
blue ribbond I guess a business and he
has talked a lot about yeah there's
something called the cognitive middle
gear so if you imagine you have three
gears and it's the same for sports so so
that's something that a lot of our
clients understand is you can do like
the long slow aerobic maybe you go for a
brisk walk or a jog you can do that for
maybe hours at a time if you just sort
of keep going it's nice and legible
you're not really punishing the body
then you have the high gear which is
like sprinting and you just go and
you're very intentional and you work
very hard for a short period of time and
then there's the middle gear which is
actually where most athletes to talk to
train and actually it's what really does
in the most harm is basically just
crushing yourself for long periods of
time like 30 minutes or an hour that's
how people think they should train right
they go sprint is a 10 out of 10 the
middle gear is as I say or 1/8 exactly
do for half an hour I know you're not
sprinting right yeah all right and and
people do that they're lighting bolt
yeah like three people in the world well
actually he just sprints for 15 seconds
then he's some chicken nuggets
but or 10.59 seconds anyway but so
people when they think that they're
gonna train what they're gonna do is
they're gonna go out and it's gonna run
as hard as I can for an hour and that's
like absolutely the worst way to train
but it's also the worst way to use your
brain so if you have the cognitive load
gear so that's exactly like sitting and
thinking you know contemplating just
letting your mind wander you know that's
when you get your best ideas but we
don't really let ourselves do that and
then there's the high gear which is
wearing can I stop you on that for a
second because I don't know if I wrote
yeah I did write this down an attention
span man like we talked about sharpness
a moment ago right and I feel less sharp
than I did at age 31 still I feel leaps
and bounds I'd like infinitely better
than I was two years ago when I first
made that phone call it to you but I
don't feel as sharp as I did it at
thirty-one but I feel like I'm getting
close to that but maybe one of the
problems I listen to too many podcasts
oh you so this is and I I'm certainly
guilty of that too you know I have a
free moment what can I do in this free
moment I can you know a podcast is the
perfect way I can put more information
into my brain which is definitely
probably not what I need definitely
probably not what I need right now and
so what what you should be doing again
is long periods of that you know low
gear where the mind is just allowed to
you know be getting bored allows you to
come up with all kinds of great ideas we
just don't that doesn't happen anymore
but when you want to achieve something
you do this high gear hi folks intention
or no distractions you get stuff done
but what we spend most of our time doing
is we spend time in the middle gear
which is I'm working on this project
away I'm gonna check my email
oh look Facebook I just got a
notification on my phone and you'll
constantly be my bother there's constant
stuff coming in but you're never
actually intentionally doing something
it's just let this continuous load of
information that you cannot actually
have a process that's the Congress in
middle gear and that's what we spend
most of our time doing continuously task
switching and never focusing on one
thing and then giving up that
opportunity to say you stood in line
waiting for coffee or something well
that's an opportunity to be in the very
lowest gear yeah but people don't do
that anymore they're gonna oh I'm gonna
go into the middle gear and I'm just
gonna scroll through a newsfeed right
now right well in a while the TV is on
in fact
did you guys have received Back to the
Future Part two classes there's a so it
takes place in far in the future in 2015
and so this is a like mid-80s right so
it's like 30 years in the future and so
it's 2015 and there is the scene oh my
god it obviously they never get the
future sort of technology right and so
they just sort of iterate on what they
ever the existing technology is so
there's still fax machines and
televisions but he's watching television
in his voice commanded so it's like this
sort of serial EXA equivalent and he
turns it on he has six six channels
playing at once on the same TV and that
seems to be the perfect metaphor for
what we're doing now we're listening to
a podcast while on Twitter watching the
television and the radios playing at the
same time it's six different channels
but they're just coming from these
different sources and you're right if
there's a free moment I will put on a
podcast and man I mean there is some
days because I'm extremely introverted
so I spend most of my time alone but am
I really spending my time alone yeah and
and and so I may not be around other
people where it's it's it's it's not a
two-way communication right but it's
sort of this the seeping in I remember
David Foster Wallace my favorite writer
he he the reason he said he didn't have
internet at home is he said if if I can
get out they can get in and he didn't
mean it in some like government
conspiracy way he meant like they can
get in like and I'm my god you guys are
blowing on mine right now because when I
was 31 I did these series of weird
experiments because I don't think
minimalism is about deprivation but
sometimes I'll temporarily deprive
myself of something to see whether or
not it's truly adding value to my life
so what I'm thinking about right now is
let's get rid of podcast for the next
week well how is that going going to
mine yeah yeah yeah our mind merge
balance thrive in the minimalism that
it and no actually we actively encourage
people to unsubscribe and unfollow us on
social media it's this ongoing thing
we're like if we're not adding value see
like please don't feel compelled to do
it
um but yeah if you do feel compelled
ania feel free to subscribe until you
stop getting value from it that's okay
too
and and and what I'm thinking though is
when I was 31 I moved I was trying to
get out of debt so I moved into this
really small apartment Dayton Ohio
second most affordable city in the
country and I was five hundred dollar
apartment in a very nice neighborhood in
Dayton and I moved in there and I it was
like during the weekend so I didn't have
internet that weekend can't come Monday
I'm gonna ready to call the internet
company I'm like huh maybe I can go
without a home internet for a month just
to test it out see what happens right no
internet at home now keep in mind I also
make a living online but I'm like I'll
try it out for a month and a month went
by and it was the most productive month
I've ever had because a month earlier I
had a couple months earlier I guess I
went when I moved out my marriage ended
I just never gotten another TV I didn't
bring a TV back into my life and I was
completely fine with that I rediscovered
these things called books and they're
amazing and and then I move and I didn't
have internet and then a couple months
later I said okay I'm gonna go without
my phone for 60 days and the first thing
you learn is there aren't very many pay
phones anymore but also you learn the
special kind of loneliness because you
come home and all the pacifiers are gone
my TV isn't there my internet isn't
there so I can't check the likes and the
tweets and the and the news and then my
phone isn't there oh my god what am I
going to do with my time well I guess
I'll read our alright I'll create
something and it was it was truly the
most productive time in my life we wrote
drafts for all four of our books I'm not
well I have one novel and then three
books that Ryan and I wrote together
during this period of time going without
internet and it started with that phone
then she brought the phone back into my
life but you
it in a much more deliberate way like to
actually make phone calls I mean it's a
weird thing we call it a phone but it's
basically a pocket computer right and
it's a distraction machine and I'm what
I'm realizing right now is wow I am
distracted in ways that that crept back
into my life and it's making me start to
to reevaluate some of those distractions
so so that's interesting tinnitus that
you said earlier my attention isn't as
good as it was when I was 31 and then
you said when I was 31 I didn't have
internet and all of a sudden the pieces
thoughts a sort of fall into place
exactly yeah and it's hard to sometimes
find these correlations so you step back
and and have these these conversations I
think that's why these these kinds of
conversations so important I love I do
spend about 90% of my time alone
but it makes another 10 to 20 percent of
the time where I'm with people it makes
these conference I have these kinds of
conversations all the time I feel like I
wish I'd brought a microphone with me
all the time because the conversations I
tend to have are more meaningful as a
result we can start you know and I'm
happy to scrutinize my own life all the
time and say hey I'm far from perfect
let let me figure out what's wrong so I
can improve on it incrementally and see
it sample that you're setting for your
kid as well is something I think about a
lot now if you don't want your kids to
spend all of their time scrolling
through a newsfeed then why are you
teaching them to do it by doing that
yourself right you lead by example
yeah well there's one thing I've been
doing recently that has house helped me
out a lot I wrote an essay about this
Sean I put a link to it in the show
notes it has to do with you know if if
you and I are sitting at a table for
dinner right all three of us are just
seated at the table having dinner and I
get a phone call and it's an iPhone chol
I have to take right now I'm going to
say excuse me while I take this phone
call I'm gonna step outside I'll be over
here over here somewhere right but but
but we don't do the same thing for text
messages we just break out the phone oh
yeah yeah go ahead and keep talking to
me uh-huh I'm just that's fine yeah
and for those of you watching this on
the video podcast you can see I'm just I
just pull my phone out and and you guys
and I'm like fake nodding or
huh and so what I started doing that
like there are times where I absolutely
have to like write something down or
something's gonna break me away from the
conversation and if I know that it's
essential what I'll say is hey please
excuse me for a minute while I take this
message and I and it makes me realize
like okay am I actually gonna excuse
myself from the table to do this I'll do
this at home now too so be me and backs
and ll we're eating dinner together I
say hey can you excuse me for a second I
really need to send a message right now
while I'm remembering it or can you
excuse me for a second I really need to
go write something down so I can
remember it later and that way I can be
fully engaged in this conversation and
people were really understanding when
you do that because it's it's almost
weird to them right because we become so
accustomed to having these barriers in
front of us I'm just holding this
machine between us and we've created
these metaphorical but also literal
barriers in our everyday conversations
and talk about I mean the attention span
now the the study I read recently and
maybe you have more information about
this 8 to 59 seconds the average
American attention span so I don't know
how they measure that but I I know that
that even me I'm someone who can get
pretty obsessive and deeply focused on
things I have OCD like legitimately will
get super obsessed I'm more obsessive
than I am compulsive but I will I will
have tunnel vision whereas Ryan if you
were here today you know he's like a
butterfly and then I'm OCD he's a DD is
the inside joke and it makes for this
interesting dynamic but but even with me
I've noticed this sort of this cultural
a dee dee has infected me as well right
because it's become commonplace and it's
almost like I've just followed suit and
it makes reading books harder it makes
it makes doing the the prolong the deep
work as Cal Newport which I strongly
recommend that book if you haven't
checked it out it's it'll make you just
sort of requestion everything that it
doesn't have to do with like really
hunkering down and creating the optimal
space for doing the best work and work
that you can be proud of you know I look
back at all the deep work I've done from
years past and those are the things I'll
look back on and say oh those are like
their assets in a way like I wrote that
book or we made this film and it was
yeah
of work but it was a lot of really
focused work and there was super
attention paid to that not perfection
but putting your best foot forward and
getting into that creative state and
really doing it so there's something to
be said for that and and our attention
is slowly eroding but I don't think it
has to yeah I wonder how much of it is
has a biological underpinning right is
is are we just seeing on social media
you know the shorter and shorter videos
it used to be three minutes wasn't it
was the the average YouTube clip and now
like you say it's like down to less than
a minute now yeah yeah well in there was
vine remember vine form there was a
second video yeah and and that that I
mean all the vine is gone is essentially
the same thing with Instagram and all
these other platforms that that are like
give me in and by the way it's all done
so that advertisers advertisers can
aggregate more eyeballs onto their
product or service right and so give me
15 seconds of your attention right now
right as if it's them but is it the most
important thing in the moment usually
not I just want I mean so it's probably
some sort of loop here right where the
the short videos are creating its short
attention span but I wonder how much of
it other problems like people are not
well slept they're not in a strong
social support group they're eating
crappy food they're not moving and they
don't get any sunshine and therefore all
they're capable of is 12 seconds of
attention or whatever is right so
whether you know how much of it has a
biological underpinning is my question
yeah yeah and lead it's this downward
spiral right that you don't even notice
that you're falling as well because yeah
that's one of the symptoms of just
follow the incentives right that
probably got some metric on the back end
there they're doing they call it a
multi-armed bandit you know it's like a
randomized control trial with 800
different arms they're like oh this is a
1 right let's go do that you know that
they're just following what works well
I've got some questions here from from
our audience I figure we dive into some
of those Natalie is asking is there a
link between excess material possessions
and an increase in mental health issues
and so I tweeted something about this
not that long ago and so if we were to
get a lightning round answer my pity
answer would be excess is a sign of
instability and I had someone say well
[Applause]
as if I meant mental instability
actually I didn't I think there are a
bunch of other if we having excess means
often we're in stable and a whole bunch
of areas of our life it could be
relationships it could be health
instability it could be creative
instability career instability financial
instability and we try to compensate we
try to fill a void by by having the
material things and and you probably
know about the chimp studies where the
the if you if you give a chimpanzee a
banana they eat the banana if you give
them enough bananas for them to eat and
share with the people are the people the
chimps around them that will share if
you give them a hoard of bananas they
will fight other chimps to the death to
protect their hoard which is just going
to rot they're not going to be able to
eat all these bananas and I'm wondering
quite often do we do the same thing that
we have this sort of irrational desire
to to consume yeah we were before that
we were talking about Chris Thalia
referring to consumerism is sort of the
people being barracudas like being
attracted the next shiny object but do
you think there's any tie to sort of
this desire to increase our status or
material wealth with mental health
issues yeah I think it's difficult to
figure out what's what's chicken-and-egg
but you know you say instability else to
think of uncertainty so being anytime
you're uncertain of anything you will
sort of hold on to anything which may
give you some uncertainty view some
certainty or you know you're uncertain
about whether you'll need that in the
future so I'm just gonna have it anyway
just in case right dangerous but there's
where I was going with that is somewhere
that I can't remember now so so so I
actually wrote this down here you've got
that this is according to the Happy
Planet Index the two least happy
countries in the world are Chad and
Luxembourg so for two utterly different
reasons I'm assuming right chad is like
talk about true instability or true
uncertainty
there's a threat of violence in every
moment of every day asleep or awake if
you're living in Chad Luxembourg is
probably I think the richest per capita
country in in the world you paid the
most for the least amount of work I just
read though this weekend's well there
you go and we're talking so there you
can have yes with a certain level of
uncertainty you're going to feel
instability and that's probably going to
lead to some sort of mental health
problems as well especially a
dissatisfaction in life no question
about that in fact when you look at and
a lot of these depression surveys
sadness surveys least happy country
surveys the war-torn countries tend to
be at the bottom of us at least happy
places right but then they're also like
these weird anomalies like Luxembourg or
the United States where people have by
and large material wealth relative to
places like chat or Rwanda but the the
amount of dissatisfaction I think a lot
of has to do with with being comparing
ourselves to each other the competitive
nature of consumerism in a way yeah
that's the thing I was going to mention
was that there are so many things that
we do with our environments that creates
the physiology of uncertainty so if if
it's the the diet that you're eating
increases some kind of systemic
inflammation we know that that's in
certain subsets of depression you know
inflammation is directly linked so if
the dyers inflammatory that's going to
cause or can cause in susceptible people
depression that makes you feel uncertain
so could that then you know then in
order to get some of those beneficial
feelings you know retail therapy could
could be one of those I was gonna say so
that's been in my past as well when I
was feeling at my worse at a desk a
hedge fund with plenty of disposable
income but being like death know
girlfriend's brain fog I would self
soothe with a lot of things including
retail therapy was very easy to go onto
the internet and research a new product
and then buy it from amazon.com and some
types of stuff would turn up and I
wouldn't even remember why I ordered you
know like even though it's been two days
researching it before I bought it and
there's a certain amount of dread you
see the black show up and you're like
what did I do you know like [ __ ] have
this really sheepish relationship with
the person that took the deliveries that
the
hedge funds you know he's like home now
I guess I did do that or something else
but I self soothed with a lot of things
I self soothe with sugar and the
internet and bike racing and all kinds
of things our sister you know your
there's something wrong with you and how
do we stop there oh stop yourself
soothing what are the steps it's like
any problem like I said it you have to
find out what's causing the problem in
the first place if you want to solve any
problem you have to know what caused it
I can't think of many examples we just
punish yourself because you like to do
retail therapy figure out what it is
that makes you feel the way that there
needs you to do that is it sunlight
deficiency it could be a sunlight
deficiency or it could be a social
connection deficiency which is and so
that was that was another thing that
creates uncertainty is that we are wired
to feel the same to be part of the tribe
and when you're continuously exposing
yourself so social media is a perfect
example to all these other people who
look better or they're different at
least you know that unites me alright
it's not necessarily reflective of
what's really going on but you don't
hire you don't feel part of the group
you don't feel like you're the same as
anybody else and feeling different again
that drives physiological changes again
in the brain in our immune system that
then has those same downstream effects
so it could be so many different things
in the environment that make you feel
different or make you feel uncertain and
then that can can drive whatever then
that the behavior is being shopping or
boy Simon has this really interesting
technique that I think's worse imagining
Simon is are whose only theme of the
year so we're very very lucky and I've
added some quite brilliant people over
the last few years and Simon is one of
them he's a professor of public health
and a performance psychologist he works
with the World Tour cycling team team
BMC and with some of the athletes that
he works with he has them break that
horrible constant comparison thing on
social media by having people reach out
to the person you know so you've seen
this highlights we love somebody else's
life oh this woman is the best cyclist
that ever lived she has the nicest
cleanest bikes her family are so perfect
I bet she gets eight and a half hours of
sleep every night she has the most
perfect diet no reach out to that woman
connect with her go for a bike ride with
her and the chances are she's going to
tell you know you're in my life is just
as much of a disaster as yours this is
the only thing I post on social media
the highlights real yeah and it just
breaks that illusion immediately and
suddenly you get it so I know that's the
technique that he uses with the people
he works with and what people might find
helpful yeah I think realizing that what
we see on TV and then online is a is a
construct and I think there's nothing
wrong with putting your best foot
forward I think quite often we want to
do that like I want this to be a good
podcast episode I want to put my best
foot forward here but but also realizing
that that's what other people are doing
is they're putting their best foot
forward it's not the total picture right
if you pose for a picture you go to
Sears and they get the portraits there I
they don't to say you know give me an
ugly face or scowl they say smile right
and so just realize that that's what
people are doing they're posing for a
picture and I don't think there's
anything inherently wrong and these
these are his words as well actually I
should make clear is that there's
nothing wrong with comparison per se
like that's how humans make meaning of
something right if you just found out I
know maybe play some game and you get a
score you don't know what that score
means until you compare it to somebody
else's score and so that's how humans
find meaning in anything so there's
nothing wrong with comparison per se
like you're going to compare yourself
with somebody else on the on the
Internet
while you're doing that all the time
that's how we find meaning in things
especially things with a number
associated with or does it go wrong okay
comparing with someone's highlights
really all the time right this is my VR
I just PR this deadlift and I'm gonna
put on Instagram now just getting
started and you can barely lift the bar
in fact you're not even sure your form
is right and you're worried about
throwing your back out here's this
picture of this super muscled guy
lifting 500 pounds or something and
doing it flawlessly sure that's there
this is what makes me so mad about help
like health coaches performance coaches
even doctors who feel the need to post
naked or topless selfies on social media
when like literally that has never
helped anybody ever I'm fairly certain
it's not entirely inspired it's not
totally inspiring and like that's
certainly something that many people in
our company could do but it literally
benefits nobody like we have everybody
has a different history everybody has a
different starting point
you know there's absolutely nothing
about the person looking at that that's
the same as what you were at whatever
given point that allows them to then use
you as inspiration because everything's
different
so all it does is
you want for failure I just I mean the
people who do that even those who are
ostensibly you know helping others with
their health that just makes me really
mad other thing that's completely
unnecessary yeah yeah I think about my
partner backs I mean she has just
phenomenal genetics on top of having her
she's a dietitian so she she's really
helped me out we partnering with you all
going through all these health problems
like just having her there to be really
supportive but also understanding and
she understands about nutrition really
well but she also has really great
genetics and and I can't plan to have a
six-pack abs like her even though you
know it that's just obviously the
lifestyle that she that she lives and
leads lends itself to that but also a
lot of is she was born with that and she
unless she were really screw it up she's
going to look great on her own right and
and I think what you're talking about is
you you you have some you know person
who's posting the shirtless picture and
and either a they're on you're just
dramatic amounts of steroids and that's
never part of the the diet plan that's
an exercise plan that's recommended and
it's a misrepresentation I think about
um we're gonna really go on on this tour
a three-city tour I've learned my lesson
on a 50 city tour two old three days
it's perfect that's right so it's it's
called the simply southern tour we're
talking about money and minimalism and
you minimalized you're told a that's
right and we're doing the South
Dave Ramsey I don't know if y'all are
familiar with with Dave but he's got a
big radio show and we're going out with
his team let's just talk about money and
minimalism but his daughter is doing our
Nashville event with us in July and she
has a book called live your life not
theirs and I'm sorry I should called
love your life not theirs and I think
that that's that's really what you're
trying to convey here is you can look at
someone else's life and you can say oh
that's an interesting ingredient I never
thought about incorporating that into my
life that could make my life better
potentially and bring that into your
life but it's really about creating your
own recipe and loving your life not not
their life and I think that's the one
thing with social media where I'm
endlessly scrolling and I'm like a
zombie lost in the glowing screen
that's when it becomes problematic let's
see we've got a question here from
Joshua we'll hook Joshua asks what's the
best way to support someone dealing with
a serious health problem for example
cancer or MS or Lyme disease my pithy
answer here is the road the support is
paved with understanding and I'll just
expand on that a little bit I when
Beck's and I first started dating was
sort of at the beginning of where my
health was really starting to decline
and and she was like I mean she was
weary for sure like what is going on I
really care about you I love you but I'm
really worried about you too but she
never she worked really hard to
understand what was going on and
throughout all the difficult moments she
didn't baby me or there was no sort of
infantile treatment of my symptoms or
whatever but she worked really hard to
understand what was going on so that she
could try to sympathize with with what I
was going through so for you all what
what are some of the best ways if if
Joshua will hook here is dealing with a
friend or a loved one who has cancer or
MS or Lyme disease well how what he can
what can he do to best support that
person well I think a big part of it is
understanding what the person is going
through on a technical basis if that
person is spending a good amount of
their time on the internet researching
their condition the chances are they're
learning some useful information and
that we get that all the time with
people we work with they come to us and
they perhaps know more about their
situation than we do which is a really
interesting thing and I think you know
supporting someone like that it that
might be a helpful thing to do to kind
of match them with that level of
understanding of the specific condition
so that you can have a meaningful
conversation with them and be on the
same page as exactly placating them with
niceties yeah you actually don't start
talking to you and you won't understand
what the hell they're talking about and
so it's very difficult to have a
conversation and of course you but the
person who's ill will immediately pick
up on that like what's the point of
talking to you you don't even understand
what I'm going through you know so yeah
I think that might be an important thing
I think being
being an ally in whatever it is that
they're trying to do is very important
so if to say all the conditions that
were mentioned you could try certain
lifestyle factors be they dietary or
environmental and you know it as much as
you can
doing that with them I think is super
important because the number of times
you see one person and a family decides
the certain way and then the rest of the
family just continues to eat the way
that they were eating before and all of
a sudden you've just isolated this
person and then you know if they're
dealing with a serious condition at the
same time plus they're being isolated
have to do everything else differently I
think that's you know it's very
difficult to then balance out the pros
of what they're trying to do versus the
cons are then you know being isolated
from other members of the family so if
everything can be done as a team I think
that's going to make a big difference
and then you know something that we
maybe don't do enough of is whenever
somebody's really struggling to deal
with something and they tell you about
it you know there's people kind of split
into two groups but but half say if it's
50% of people will try and offer
solutions so if something's really
struggling with something be it who's to
say as a disease and this sort of up
there just need to offload that talk
about it and then they don't necessarily
need solutions from you they just need
to know that you're there for them so
you just need to say man that really
sucks I'm sorry and so rather than try
it's such a problem I have is and I know
I've gotten way better and especially my
current relationship but I'm a problem
solver yeah and so I just want to show
up and say well here's the seven steps
to fix exactly and index like hey shut
the [ __ ] up and listen to me I just want
you to listen and I think that that is
so key like sometimes it's just
listening and and not just nodding your
head along say uh-huh
but like but but but trying to
understand what they're going through
just by listening and if they if they
really want some solution they lost
Joshua look also asked how can we take
responsibility for our health but not
obsess about it and and my short answer
to this is obsession is helpful until
it's no longer useful like sometimes I
actually think obsession can be kidding
can for me I got really when we first
saw
talking I got really obsessed with okay
I need to fix this right but there's a
certain level of obsession that is
endless rumination that doesn't do
anybody any good it's just me being
neurotic about about it the same thought
over and over again right you just get
around in circles exactly and so so
there was a level of obsession that
allowed me to get really deep and get
committed to fixing this I think but but
but there comes a time where it's like
okay I know what I need to do now I can
give myself permission to to stop
obsessing over it or this this endless
worry you know get if you give up worry
there's nothing to worry about it would
be another pithy answer for you what do
you guys think about that
personally I found habits incredibly
useful there's a really good book by
Charles Duhigg that Simon often
recommends to our clients on why habits
are important how you form them and then
you don't you just don't think I do
stuff without thinking about it like if
someone was to observe me from the
outside during my day they were like
that's weird like why is he doing that
why is he doing that why is eating this
like why did he go to bed so early why
did you have dinner at 4 o'clock in the
afternoon those are not conscious
decisions that my family is making every
day all those things are now on
autopilot right so the the premise of
the book is or you probably remember a
time when you reverse your car out the
driveway and it took an awful lot of the
prefrontal cortex right you're using
higher-order reasoning to understand how
to get this thing out into the road and
then you know the tenth time you do it's
on autopilot and you can have your kid
in the back talking to you and listen to
the radio whilst reversing the current
and so the same is true of anything you
can put these things onto a habit so
they're basically on autopilot you know
every time I boil the kettle I do 10
press ups and it's just something that
happens automatically I'm not depleting
willpower in order to make that happen
so your habits to me of a really useful
the way that I approach I guess is
probably similar to one of your pithy
like your pithy response and which is
that I think you should fix the things
that you can fix or that you're willing
to fix and then don't worry about it
so for instance one thing that I've done
recently is our bought reverse osmosis
water filter for my house because I'm
fairly concerned about some of the
things that end up in the municipal
water supply okay and I am willing to
buy water filters so that most of the
water that I drink is filtered the other
water the
I drink out in the world don't worry
about it I have literally no control
over that I'm done I've done that eighty
percent or more I know that's gonna have
a net benefit the other stuff just don't
worry about it and I think you can apply
that to pretty much everything be it
your food or you know other aspects of
your environment you know fix what you
can fix and what's easy and what it
you're willing to fix and then beyond
that I really you know it's definitely
not worth worrying about it and worrying
about it it's gonna is actually gonna be
is actually gonna be detrimental yasiel
serenity prayer I grew up Catholic and
they want mommy stories you know a
rosary beads out and praying they give
me the courage to change the things like
can change yeah the same thing and that
is filtered water by the way it's not
under our control anymore is is Wi-Fi
right so we we work with a lot of people
that are worried about that but there's
not a great deal that you can do if you
live in LA for example in London you
know you put on your phone and there's
like 25 Wi-Fi networks so even if you
could turn it off you can move up to
your house baby yeah you can we did my
Wi-Fi signal is the only signal but then
you might create social isolation
problem like which is the worst thing
but yeah understanding what's under your
control I think is very important
Ruffalo asks how can I safely recover
from burnout my pithy answer is
extinguish the fire before rebuilding
your home III think that's one thing
that that I did struggle with when you
and I first talked was like I didn't
feel like I was burnt out even though
maybe I was to a certain degree because
I you know was just I was moving from
inertia right and so like I was still
continuing oh well yeah of course we've
got another 50 city tour it's not a
problem and then I realized pretty
quickly like oh hey if I really want to
get this out of control I I do need to
put out the fire before I start
rebuilding there's this home right
there's a line from our book everything
that remains it's actually in the
documentary there's a scene I'm out in
the the salt flats I'm reading from it
my marriage ends my mom dies and in the
line from the book is even while Rome is
burning there's some how time for
shopping at IKEA
and that that was the thing light and I
have nothing against like he is
completely fine if you want you know
cheap breakable furniture but the the
the the the problem with IKEA wasn't
IKEA the problem was me it was like
there's all the house is still burning
and I'm trying to rebuild it as as you
know I'm not dealing with the actual
problem I'm covering out by buying the
nice accoutrements that are gonna make
my new space look you know a hospitable
I guess so how do you all when you talk
to folks about burnout what do you talk
about
I mean you often hear this term adrenal
fatigue which i think is overused and
and I think there is a such thing as
adrenal fatigue but but I think we often
use it as we use it just explain
exhaustion and can maybe differentiate
yet so adrenal fatigue is a it's a very
well it's now the artist formerly known
as adrenal fatigue yeah say that we
don't we don't say that anyway we call
it hypothalamic-pituitary-adrenal axis
dysfunction which is a lot more of a
mouthful but it's interesting because
the the original thought process which
came largely from work by hans selye a
who was a physiologist who essentially
they say would have won a nobel prize if
he hadn't come up with this idea but it
basically eventually you know so if
you're stressed you make cortisol as
your stress hormone and then eventually
you get to a point where you make so
much cortisol that your adrenals get 40
and they stop being able to make good
soul and I've heard people refer this as
hypercortisolism yes so there is a thing
there are there is a thing called
hypercortisolism in in like there is
something which is very dangerous called
out of Addison's disease where basically
or adrenal your adrenal glands for
various potential reasons just stop make
cortisol at all and that you know can
lead to death very quickly but you know
when you look at in reality like your
your adrenals could still make cortisol
if they were given the right inputs
right it's not that they just don't work
anymore it's for some reason your body
has decided that making more or less
calls so isn't a good idea and that's
there's many different inputs in
that system that was a problem I have
when we do the first test my cortisol
levels were low cortisol is a real thing
and it does make people feel bad but
there's nothing wrong with your adrenal
our fatigue they may have you know they
may have hiked also they may have local
so they may we there are lots of
different tests you can do we try and
stimulate the adrenal glands to make
cortisol and people who have fatigue
some of them are high some of them alone
you know it you cannot just say it's
adrenal fatigue it may you know in some
cases there may be local cell being
produced but again you have to work your
way back it's not just because they're
tired there's some kind of reason why
why that why that's happening mmm okay
so if if someone's dealing with burnout
what what do you recommend to them I
mean it's my default answer isn't it you
have to understand what caused the burn
out in the first place don't you yeah
yeah I think you know complete so
complete taking a step back what we like
to do is is look inside so we do do a
fair amount of testing we've actually
reduced the amount of testing that we do
up front because so much of the the
stuff that benefits people is the
lifestyle interventions you know we talk
about diet and sleep and you know so
stress is super important like where are
your stresses coming from you know many
people their stressor may be that
cognitive middle load like they're just
12 hours a day at work just continuously
never processing anything properly but
it's just like stuff is coming in
continuously that's a stressor on the
body so figuring out where you know what
the issue is and then also figuring out
what it is that you can actually stop
doing what you don't need to do or what
you can change and actually for you know
a lot of us feel like all the stuff that
we do is super essential but in reality
that's that's not really true and I'm
sure it's the case for everybody in this
room even though we feel like we're
maybe good at handling our priorities
you know there's always gonna be stuff
that there's gonna be a drain that you
don't really need to do so so I'm like
like you've both said it since you find
out what the main issues are and you
can't you can't rebuild while it's still
on fire right you need to step back you
know fix everything and allow yourself
that time so people often get stressed
about oh my god I'd my work you know
this is caused by work but I have
work and you know otherwise it can't pay
the bills and so then more stresses
creep in when you're trying to fix
things because you know the things that
you're trying to fix are the things that
you need to do so you know giving
yourself permission and time to do some
of that is super important I wrote an
essay recently called essential
non-essential and junk and it started
with like talking about the material
things in our life the average average
American household has 300 thousand
items in it
that's according to LA Times and and I
think when we look at that stuff we we
tend to think it's all essential or at
least like it's gonna add some value to
my life you've not now some day and some
far-off non-existent hypothetical future
I'll somehow magically started getting
value from that just the things yeah
yeah the thing that's in my attic it
will all of a sudden like seep into my
house and start adding value but I think
the truth is there are some things that
are truly essential and most of us have
the same baseline essentials the the
specifics vary but housing and clothing
and food and and the hygiene products
like there are certain things that that
we can say all right these are what we
perceive to be essentials and they'll
change from person to person somewhat
but there are true essential items then
there are these non essentials the
things that truly add value to our lives
like we have these microphones right now
I could live without these microphones
but it's gonna be a lot harder for us to
make a high quality podcast without them
right this but there are non essentials
to me and I have to recognize that but
they add value to my life the third and
I think most of the things that we own
should should fit in that non-essential
category we bring them in deliberately
because we know they're gonna serve some
sort of purpose so that bring us joy in
some way and the third category is the
junk the things that we pretend that
value but they don't actually add value
or how things are holding on to just in
case or the things I multiple stores I
don't want to deal with it right now or
whatever it might be and I think the
same is what you were just saying holds
true for the the stuff that we're
dealing with the stressors in our life
right there are some essential stressors
and that maybe we have to keep those
around but then what are the things that
are non-essential that we can remove for
a temporary period of time and then once
we're recovering we can maybe bring them
back in individually slowly and then
what's the junk that we never have to
want to bring back into our lives ever
again you gossip is one I think about
you know that that is there was an
evolutionary imperative for gossip it
probably helped us evolve to to where we
are today but it doesn't mean it's
necessary in my life anymore and so I've
completely removed that from my life
because I don't I I don't get any value
from whatsoever that's a stressor that
is no longer there anymore jealousy is
something that yeah we probably evolved
to need a jealousy over a period of time
but it's not something that I find to be
a particularly useful emotion now and so
I've decided why don't I just consider
that junk get rid of it and I think that
that helps me deal with with some of the
burnout but I think I'm gonna go back
and sort of reassess like what are the
things that are stressing me out one of
the one of those stressors are junk and
how can i how can I get rid of those
Jason asks why do we seem to have more
health problems than ever before is it
pesticides hormones antibiotics sugar
something else yes yes it's got to say
it's a lot of those it's probably a
hundred more things that we've known no
one can measure or the Rhian measuring
or that we don't know about
you mentioned inflammation earlier yeah
and I know that I had in fact I'm still
doing the curcumin supplements and we're
gonna I think we have a question here
about supplements somewhere and we'll
deal with that but inflammation is
something that we hear about but it's
something that we haven't talked a whole
lot of Bell as a culture until recently
but now we're hearing more and more
about it so can we talk about what we
mean we hear this this sort of catch-all
term of inflammation so it's basically
your body responding to some to
something and usually and traditionally
it's a good thing right so if you get a
cut in your foot that area becomes
inflamed and that's your immune system
responding making sure it cleans out any
junk that may have gotten in and then
starts to you know initiate that the the
process of repair
and you know a lot of the you know there
are some very smart people who say that
we shouldn't you know be against him
from you know everybody's like it talks
about information being a bad thing and
it's it's usually not it's it's the the
process is beneficial however in the
setting of a continuous stressor which
produces continuous inflammation then we
know that that's when you start to see
issues and it can be you know pretty
much anywhere like we've talked about
the fact that it can affect the brain
you know spots in the body where you
have continuous information so you know
might then cause a cancer because it's
like a continuous repair process can you
know cells continuously being damaged
and having to be repaired that can be a
trigger for something like a cancerous
growth so it's it's any response of the
body to something which it perceives to
be foreign and it could be bacterial or
something else and it's usually a good
thing but when you don't remove what's
causing it then it can cause issues and
it seems that we were highly inflamed
these days I know I was and and taking
some of these supplements actually
helped it was the first things that that
I had taken that by the way you all had
me on a supplement regimen that was
terrifying
but it was extremely helpful in fact
things got worse before they got better
at some points especially with once we
fix the gut thing and then we went to
the mercury stuff so we did the heavy
metals tests I had really high levels of
mercury really high levels of strontium
because it was in a damn supplement that
I was taking and I had decently high
levels of arsenic and I think cadmium
and and and and and so in dealing with
that we did this whole chelation therapy
and was a bunch of supplements there was
one point I was taking 112 pills a day
and which was a lot of fun like just
yeah but I mean like I said you know I
was well I was laser focused and I think
there was maybe one day where I missed
one of my three rounds this is why we
recommended the football protocol that
we would not suggest this to submit most
people and you know so most of this is
with the intention of you get to the
point where you don't need any
supplements right that's
yeah yeah and so right now I'm taking
fewer supplements than I had in the last
two years but they're still you know
it's a multivitamin and human stuff that
I take but but for the most part I'm not
taking the the whole litany of yeah you
stuff pockets full of pills but there
was a period where I actually I got I
was getting worse because that chelation
the therapy I mean and you can talk
about the the science behind it but you
can't go in your body and say okay body
please remove the mercury but I'd like
to keep the zinc and the selenium and
all the good stuff you could just leave
that and there that'd be great and so I
think my immune system was pretty
radically compromised last winter I had
a tour stopped in Washington DC and I
couldn't leave my hotel room in fact I
was gonna go to hospital I was to felt
too ill to leave my hotel room well I
ended up having hand foot and mouth
disease which is what usually
four-year-olds have and my four-year-old
had it and I caught it because I think
my immune system was relatively
compromised at the time and I basically
spent all winter last winter relatively
sick dealing and I think a lot of it had
to do with my immune system was pretty
affected by the this chelation therapy
and we did the 10-day fast and that I
only lasted six days in one hour on but
there were a lot of things that that
that I did that actually you know it was
getting worse expelling the the toxins
for and I know that has become a
whoo-whoo word and we don't mean it in
any sort of woowoo way but there was a
lot of getting worse before before
getting better and I think I think
inflammation was a big part of that but
then it was also this these these toxins
they were my body can we talk a little
bit about toxins so the analogy that
islets use for that kind of process is
if you looked at heart surgery right in
the middle it would look like murder
towards the end it looks a lot better
right once you've been sewn back up so
that that does tend to happen sometimes
and you're right so
detoxing and toxins are the super
nonspecific thing that it's kind of iro
I'm gonna do a detox which doesn't
really mean anything however you have
people drinking like
juices with 50 grams of sugar and sale
detail detoxing yeah it doesn't make any
sense but but there are you know if you
find something specific and you know you
can't estimate for many of them and we
have various ways to do that and you
have some good data on how you might be
able to reduce the body's burden of that
which we also have good data on then in
a very targeted specific way you can do
that and mercury is one of the things so
the strontium
unfortunately we we don't know how to
get that out and that's just that's in
your bones until they turn over in about
seven years time I think Christmas the
other day so not much I mean this is
important right you should talk about
how the strontium ended up in to
supplement in the first place yes I
shouldn't be there anymore this is a
strata this is a supplement for bone
strength and so I remember I when I was
working in hospital in London for
elderly patients with osteoporosis some
of them would get I would prescribe
strontium and strontium basically goes
into the bones you know where you'd have
calcium and what it does is it makes the
bones look really good on a bone scan
but absolutely does nothing for their
strength so we kind of feel better
because they look better but actually it
doesn't really really help you at all in
terms of the strength of the perceiver
well you get the the ostensible result
that's measurable but it's not actually
doing something yeah so this is actually
you know it goes back to what you're
talking about right at the beginning
which is the importance of the
subjective experience so we can talk all
day about test results but what you
really want is to wake up with a boner
right that's like that's the Holy Grail
in like no matter what the test results
say if that's happened then you know
there's there's a big win there so so
that's the strontium but with with the
the mercury there's some we know that
basically there's no amount of mercury
that's okay basically you can get
effects at any level and the amount that
it affects a given person you know
depends on a whole number of things but
we also know that there's where the
exposures are it can be so exposures
from fish is a big one although some of
the benefits of fish seems to negate
some of the negative side effects of the
mercury so that's kinda like a 50-50
that's do the selenium content the air
selenium content of the fish it helps
produce glutathione which is one of the
main antioxidants that we use to buffer
various toxins and so that you know
overall this there's definitely a net
benefit of seafood even if it does have
some mercury in it but then it matters
the type of fish as well so Joshy was
eating some big fish right yeah yeah I
mean I was you know I think the quantity
is well I mean once or twice a day every
single day I was tuna or mahi-mahi
sashimi twice a day that's gonna be bad
yeah yeah I mean or even canned tuna
like it was all I mean and so I had to
do with the quantity but but also then I
had these metal Malcolm's my mouth which
I had taken out I sent you my dentist
information because I know that like
that's one thing that I wanted to be
really careful because and we did three
different mercury tests because I did
after the the we did the whole sort of
cleanse the the chelation therapy and
all the supplements and my mercury was
an acceptable well to name it was amazed
at how well that was absolutely worked
he had all these powders and all this
crazy stuff but it all it all worked
this magic potion I think it was very
highly scientific it with at least one
reference yeah there was there was
nothing magic about it but and then I
knew I wanted to get the metals on I
mean a they're ugly but but I didn't
care as much about that but I wanted to
make sure there's someone who was gonna
do it where it didn't leach back into my
body that's right that was the primary
concern and so we did a third test and
then the mercury was even lower after
that and I've even reintroduced some
fish back into my diet not twice a day
but maybe twice a month where where I
felt good enough that I feel like I
bring that back in now and so having
those removed and then having removed it
from my body and now just consuming a
responsible amount an appropriate amount
of fish is right it seems to be what
what was I mean it was a long road to
fix it but I'm glad we did all right I'm
gonna take steps to not go back down
that path you see how important is to
understand what's causing the problem if
you've gone to some of the IV chelation
therapists they said oh yeah no problem
I can get that mercury out no problem at
all but if you haven't stopped eating
pilot whale and you see
mouth full of mercury amalgams there
what's gonna stop that problem from
coming right back 6x later yeah yeah and
so I immediately had those taken out
right after we did the second test and
then we did the follow-up test a few
months later and make sure everything
was was gone and and the levels were
great yeah so so thank you Perry Scott I
still have a mouth full of metal
amalgams because I find the idea of
going paying I mean how much do you pay
to have your mercury amalgams for me I
mean it was hundreds of dollars but oh
yeah yeah I wasn't gonna tell me ten
thousand no no no no no was not even a
thousand dollars oh really okay so
notice less right now but yeah I mean so
I've still got a mouth full of mercury
and you've got one little one yeah I got
when I was a med students I couldn't
afford the fancy fish that's a perfect
metaphors like if we don't pay for
something now we end up paying for it
fold in the future and not not just
monetarily but worrying about it and
like the roasting over the thing and so
it's best to take care of it now let's
see we got some more questions here
Shane asks I'm trying to figure out how
to deal with chronic fatigue syndrome
okay well we just talked about fatigue
and maybe I could've asked this question
about myself too so he said I've read it
involves gut health but a discussion
would be great so chronic fatigue
syndrome we were kind of talking about
that with adrenal fatigue here and it
seems to be the same thing but via a
different name I mean we we have these
names in fact I think when he actually
submitted this question he you sever all
their acronyms that I just edited out
that but the essay might cool at myalgic
encephalomyelitis which is Emmy it's
also the same thing first okay
yeah so with me I the one thing I do
notice now is that I am I tend to sleep
I sleep about eight sometimes nine hours
a night now which is the first time I've
ever done that I go to bed really early
like Ella will be in bed by 8:00 and I
like to go to bed around 8:00 if
possible because I say yeah I still like
to get up early right and so it doesn't
always work out that way but I do i do
get minimum seven hours a night unless I
I can't help it like this morning is a
good example so the last four nights in
a row I've got this this tracker ring so
it tells me how shitty my sleep is on
nights like last night
but the last four nights I had nine
hours every single night which is great
I would wake up really refreshing this
morning I woke up before and I knew I
just knew that this is it like I am wide
awake and I can lay in bed for the next
three hours but it's not going to get
out I'm not gonna like like magically go
go back to sleep so might as well get up
and and get some writing done and so
there are times where I can fall asleep
like that I don't have a problem with
insomnia necessarily but I the days like
today I know I will be really tired
midday and I'll end up taking a nap but
there are some days even when I get nine
hours of sleep where I'm like I'm still
tired where do I go from here
like if I'm tired midday I mean yeah
maybe a nap is the answer yeah it's I
mean naps can be fabulous things and
definitely take advantage of them if you
can but the so going back to the the
chronic fatigue piece it used to be this
thing where you'd be tested for all this
stuff and then be like well we don't
know what it is but you're tired so
we'll call it chronic fatigue and now
there's there's been some fairly
interesting research at least that that
basically brings it all back to the
function of the mitochondria so that the
mitochondria are these organelles inside
your cells that basically in the
simplest form they make all of your
energy right and if the thing that makes
your energy doesn't make energy very
well then you don't have very much
energy that's kind of simple it's
mentioned a lot of other really
interesting things start in the
mitochondria like hormone production
yeah he in production right for
hemoglobin to transport oxygen so no
mitochondria and your proper [ __ ] yeah
so if you want it so if you want to make
quarters or any of your hormones the
first step happens and it happens in the
mitochondria so basically you know so
much stuff so much stuff happens there
and then what is it that makes you a
mitochondria function less well and it
could be any kind of so it could be in
the gut because then like we talked
about whether things are coming across
that you don't want to come across or
you know there's some infection in there
that's causing issues you know some kind
of systemic infection or again chronic
inflammation so some response to
something that we are not getting rid of
the source that can affect mitochondrial
function certain toxins can affect
mitochondrial nutrient deficiency
nutrient deficiency is going to fight
mitochondrial dysfunction so
since oh yes yeah rock the statins are
among toxin so I guess that there's two
parts the first part is if you're trying
to deal with chronic fatigue syndrome
try as best as you can to figure out
what it is that caused it and it could
be dietary environmental pharmaceutical
and then the next step is when you're
when you're starting to recover it's
always important to balance your efforts
so what's very common in in patients
with chronic fatigue is they feel great
on one day like I feel great today I'm
gonna go for a run and then they overdo
it and then they crash and then they
have then they're fatigued for days on
an end and until they start to feel
better again and then when they feel
better then they do loads so so the the
important thing is to do pretty much if
you can make yourself do the same amount
every day to regardless of what it is be
that exercise or activities day of daily
living or work so that on the days where
things feel a bit harder you make sure
you're still doing the same amount on
the days when you feel really great just
enjoy the fact you feel great but don't
overdo it because then you cause those
cycles in fact Chris early on you you
told me like because I'm not especially
active I'm certainly not an athlete but
during these times of of trying to get
better you rely I think you need to
exercise a little bit less which was a
weird thing to hear right because we've
it's it's sleep it's diet and it's
exercise and you're like I think maybe
you need to eat a little bit more am i
wait a minute what's going on and so I
started tracking my calories and
realized we actually realized I didn't
have to eat anymore because I was
getting a substantial enough amount of
calories and a really healthy you know
fat a lot of fats in my diet so I had a
decent number of calories but the
exercise I didn't feel like I was like I
wasn't out running marathons I don't run
at all but but you know just simple
stuff especially while I was recovering
you're like it's too many pull-ups
you're doing everyday or you're doing
way too many push-ups everyday and let's
scale that back a little bit but the
consistency is also the key where it's
like there will be days like today we're
on like I'm tired screw it I won't do I
won't do the the you know I'll wait till
the day where I'm feeling better and
then I'll just double off on everything
right so that that is key I'll have to
make sure that I've
I'm still relatively consistent but but
more consistent and also dialing back on
days where you I don't have to go balls
to the wall every I don't have more in
the tank like I did what I normally do
and I could have done so much more but I
didn't need to because I know I'm gonna
do some tomorrow yeah that's important
that's great
that's great alright let's see what else
we got here shame that's your question
Dina says what's the safest way to detox
from heavy metals on your own my
response to my pithy answer was even
LeBron James can't win alone this was
proven recently and as he was swept in
the finals can win even with teammates
pretty much long but uh but I think you
need I mean you could reach out to the
nourish balance thrive guys and and they
can help point you in the right
direction or find someone locally who's
who's gonna help you through this but I
think doing it alone is probably and
that's yeah it's got it stuff you don't
have to work with us but I would
recommend finding a coach or a clinician
to help you I mean there's so many
things that I don't know anything like
me just said a bunch of words I don't
understand if I was like had to
understand that tomorrow then I probably
go and find someone that understood it
and have them help me rather than trying
to figure out the hard way by myself and
run basketball I was it's that sport
Oliver on yeah I'm so bad with American
sports you know where sport is where
it's but yeah so I would find someone to
help you you're right but having said
that the closest we've got is Brian
Walsh is a naturopathic doctor for
Maryland that we've worked with quite
closely he's another one of the the
shoulders that we've been standing on
over the past few years and he does a
fantastic job of teaching both
biochemistry and physiology and he has a
detox course that's incredibly
evidence-based so that's available as a
training course if you go to if you just
google his net oh no don't go to
metabolic fitness procom I'll put a
length on the show notes to show forward
slash detox I think it is and then
there's a he has two courses one for
clinicians and one for patients and you
can't it's not easy to do without a
coach because it's just I mean as you
know it's incredibly involved it
involves sauna time restricted feeding
okay all right yes all right so so sauna
it's something I do pretty regularly
yeah unless I have some sort of cold I'm
skiing over a cold from this past
weekend but I'm all fine today so don't
don't worry but um I I the sauna was one
thing that that you recommended early on
and I really started that that was one
thing one of the benefit also I've been
doing cold plunge or a cold shower but
but there's a nice place here there's a
cold plunge so how cool I do that so you
know I I can talk a little bit about
heat shock proteins or cold shock
proteins but but beyond that I I start
to get lost really quickly so what are
the benefits I for in terms of detox and
I also think it's that one of the things
that really helped with my back
considerably yeah so Stefan Janice not
genius generous doctor genius has some
really useful resources online he's from
where's he from he's from Canada isn't
he yeah and he's published a number of
studies that show that metals are
preferentially excreted in sweat salsa
some metals preferentially excreted in
sweat cadmium is that I think is the the
main one mercury some too but so there's
two parts there's some things that are
that you excrete mainly through sweat
and it's very rare that people who
aren't exercising heavily nowadays sweat
a lot because your inside air
conditioning all that kind of stuff
people don't like to sweat so that's
that's definitely one benefit there's
some things you're going to get out the
some sort of what we call them
persistent organic pollutants they're
basically you know some some synthetic
compounds that only come out through
sweat so that's that's one benefit
particularly in in the in a hot so there
are two types of sauna there's the
infrared sauna which is basically red
light they're less hot but they they
make you sweat a lot but they don't make
yeah but they don't sort of cause this
heat stress whereas if you look at the
sort of the hot Sun it's like a
Scandinavian dry sauna so it's really
hot that also has a number of
cardiovascular benefits so a lot of
studies done in in Finland basically
show that the more often you sauna like
a dose-response you know the lower risk
you look your risk of heart disease
stroke type to die by
to diabetes there's even been studies
done on heating people up actually in a
hot bath rather than a sauna but people
with type 2 diabetes in their blood
sugar regulation improved so there's
kind of both the detox benefits which
you could get from either type of sauna
and then there's the sort of the
metabolic health benefits which we think
are probably going to come more from
that kind of heat stress so so at least
two times a week usually three or four
times a week I try to do 25 minutes and
a 200 degree sauna and and then do a
cold plunge or a cold shower afterward
and I can tell you that the first time I
went like you're right I I wasn't used
to sweating and in fact and I don't I
didn't like just sweat normally like I'm
not I don't have overly active sweat
glands I took Ryan the cryotherapy a few
weeks ago he was sweating in the cryo
chamber II just like just sweating like
I don't get that way right but when the
first time I went I was in the sauna is
200 degrees I've been there for five
minutes
nothing 10 minutes nothing 12 minutes I
give this one little runnel of sweat on
my forehead and then all of a sudden it
starts coming and and I realize like oh
[ __ ] I haven't I haven't actually
sweated in the last decade uh-huh it's
been a decade since I've had a place
play basketball in high school and stuff
but and I sweat all the time then but
I'd had the corporate life and then I
would sweat occasionally but not a real
like heavy sweat and I swear to you it
was like I was sweating chalk dust or
something we're like yeah and and the
stuff that was coming out of my pores
and now I do it every day not every day
but every week and and it's just become
a regular routine and it's a habitual
now and the benefits from that are that
yeah I feel that that my back and my
muscles are a lot better but I'm certain
that the one of the biggest things for
the whole detox that I did I had to do
with with the savasana heavy Solano
protocol yeah so yeah I would say don't
go at it alone
Dena can I just add that the mayor is
the one that you've got access to yes
in a lot like oh is infrared better than
dry heat I don't care who knows better
than you you've kind of I mean so this
is a very Brian thing as well like I'm
not gonna even answer that question
you've missed the point like the point
is to sweat I don't really care how you
do it right right and then if you have
access to both and congratulations pick
one that you that you'll do the most
often and go with that all right Joanne
says what are your thoughts on it on the
low carb and ketogenic and whole 30
diets my wife's name a whole thirty
right now she's on Facebook in a support
group so what does the most thirty diet
approach that was the first thing that I
did to hold thirty is a version of what
we might call a paleo template so it's
this idea of trying to recreate a diet
that was eaten 10,000 years ago when we
were hunter-gatherers and before farming
and grains and all of that right and it
focuses on micronutrient so every time
you put something into your mouth like I
was with a friend of the day and they
were spoon feeding a baby just boiled
pasta and I and the thing that made me
cringe the most was not the gluten it
was just a missed opportunity for micro
nutrition right now he talks about how a
simple nutrient deficiency can cause
mitochondrial dysfunction well you're
just putting empty carbs into your mouth
with is literally zero micro niche
unless the flour was fortified which I
guess they're obliged to do by law right
so that's interesting the gluten thing
like we've demonized gluten and I think
it's probably good but not for the right
where we were not we're not demonizing
for the right reasons that the the real
reason to demonize is like we're missing
out on all these nutrients because we're
just stuffing our face with these sort
of empty calories and empty carbs right
right
yes it's a whole thirty is focus on
minimally processed micro nutrient dense
foods you remove sugar so for many
people myself included when I first came
to this I was utterly hooked on sugar
yeah and couldn't really go more than
about an hour without eating and so
remove ripping that band-aid off quickly
and removing all the sugar can be really
helpful for people and your headaches
and stuff at first yeah I was just
really hungry it was like the main food
for so and then it completely
preoccupies you can't think about
anything but but you think I mean I
don't think you're on a ketogenic diet
now but you you yeah so I've gone you
were supposed to a ketogenic diet
is a high-fat really low carb and
moderate protein that's right yeah so
the whole xxx was where I started and I
found that tremendously helpful and like
I said my wife who coaches the athletes
that we work that she's doing one at the
moment just sort of mostly in support of
her friends I think in Santa Cruz but
you know it's very sustainable you can
go back and do it again and again and in
fact my diet now would be completely
whole 30 compliant and we really like
the book it starts with food it's very
very accessible if you're completely
brand new or you you want to try and
encourage somebody to get involved and
they're totally brand new it starts with
food by Melissa Hart work is very very
good and they have some fantastic
resources on their website whole 30.com
things like shopping lists and meal
plans and you know eat this don't eat
that type resources that you need in the
beginning so I find it very sustainable
one of the things they sell the program
on is it's only 30 days right it's like
the greasy used-car salesmen pitch well
can you do it for 30 it like you did
with Ryan right like I bet you how long
can you do this for well I guess it's a
bit different is that there's a definite
end to the program and you realize that
you know you can do anything from one
and then this is a trimming it feels
like a sacrifice in the moment but it's
not a true sacrifice it it's actually
the opposite of that it's fueling your
body even get to spend a month eating
steak and eggs sometimes people like oh
Jesus Christ I'd never really itíd liked
eating cereal in the first place you
mean I can eat bacon and eggs for
breakfast again this is fantastic right
right because we've also been sold this
bill of goods that that you know salt is
is bad and you eat the egg whites and
not the yolks and all that nonsense this
morning it was just across the road
getting some breakfast when we turned up
before before the podcast and the
breakfast that I wanted had egg whites
and when I wanted I was like can I have
whole eggs that can I have the I'm on
the yolk that's the best thing you know
you're gonna throw that way for heat the
butter eat the yolks yeah well what
we've been told you know over many years
in fact I was at the doctor's also then
had the screen on on the wall and I
won't go back to this doctor's office
because it and it was talking about
eating a diet that's low in fat
and and like me and and like you could
tell they just had this out-of-date sort
of nutritional information and and they
were talking about the food group still
and I had a little thing of the MyPlate
is now what is still wrong but it's
called my plate used to be called the
food pair no they still had the food
peralta de electronic Nord so it looked
new because it wasn't a poster was an
actual like electronic board that had
the food pyramid I'm like really you're
still talking about eating the bread
with yeah and so yeah although I mean it
goes back to a previous question we
talked about being obsessive I think
being obsessing about this stuff to a
certain extent is important but tell me
what you were saying earlier is like
yeah you want to control what you can
control
yeah you don't want to kill yourself
because of it reminded me of this
question I printed out this article I
saw this
it's from McSweeney's I'm sure you all
are familiar with McSweeney's but um
that's called the whole thirty challenge
changed my entire relationship with food
because I'm dead now I used to be just
like you overweight lethargic a carbon
sugar junky looking for my next fix
until I tried whole thirty the
incredible nutritional reset program and
experienced a profound transformation of
my body mind and spirit
I cut sugar grains alcohol Dairy legumes
and literally every other source of
nutrition out of my diet for thirty days
and I could honestly say that it has
completely changed my relationship with
food because I died on day 27 and no
longer require sustenance we'll put a
length of the whole article and in there
I think maybe the important thing I want
to illustrate here is take it seriously
but I'll take it too seriously sometimes
these things become religions and you've
got team paleo and team and another
carnivore diet this big thing and and
I've seen people who go on and they
solve these sort of autoimmune problems
and I don't it's not the carnivore diet
that's that's necessarily changing or
fixing the eczema or whatever they have
it is the fact that removing the other
things that we're causing that is most
always what you're not eating or what
you end up not eating so I mean we
mentioned whole thirty Lokar
Kito all of those diets are great
carnivore diet can be great we have some
people who we put on what you would call
a Whole Foods plant-based diet so a real
food vegan low-fat diet for a very
specific reason not long-term so
depending on who you are a whole host of
different diets maybe the best diet at
that moment in time however almost all
of them and there was a recent I think
it was two or three years ago they all
the guys who they're experts in all
these diets you know so the vegans and
the paleo guys and the low-carb guys
they it was amazing I think in New York
I think it was called the the old ways
finding common ground or something
that's what they were trying to do and
what they figured out was that they
agree on 80% of stuff which is donee
refined carbohydrates refined fats and
oils and all that kind of stuff oil you
know the oil you know so once you remove
those things actually what you're left
with is usually some plants and some
animal products and they look like food
they look like what comes out of the
ground or comes out of the animal as
soon as you've you know slaughtered it
so if you focus on those foods then
obviously you can get into the
macronutrients and keto low carb low fat
but you know the most important thing is
removing all the earth stuff so once
you've taken out two cookies in the fast
food and the pizza and all that stuff
that's the most important thing and then
you know once you've left with real food
whatever it is you that's probably the
point where most people can stop
worrying about it
yeah yeah and occasionally you will have
something that won't be part of that and
it won't be the end of the world I
recognize these things sometimes
sometimes we have these really small
wins it's important to recognize those
small wins but also recognize the small
losses if you screw something up they
don't say well I've ate half the cake I
might as well eat the other half an hour
all right
no what the heck thing you can do that
with with dieting that they set
unreasonable goals which of course they
don't meet and then they say what the
heck and then they stop even counting
and that's been shown if you have one
bad meal that doesn't mean that the
whole day is out the whole week is out
and equally don't don't punish yourself
so you know I sometimes eat cake and ice
cream but I really enjoy it and then I
don't worry about it it's a it's some
food I had are usually having it with
friends I'm enjoying I'm enjoying it in
the moment
and then don't think about it ever again
and that's the really important thing
don't punish yourself if if that does
happen but you know equally the overall
habit is the important thing yeah you
still have to form that habit yes it be
then be able to do the do the other bit
and not deviate from the habit I last
weekend had a piece of bread for the
first time probably a decade and that
was just because I couldn't digest bread
well like it would just be this
nightmare in my stomach and now that you
all have helped me fix my gut I had a
piece of a sourdough bread and it wasn't
like you know Wonder bread or something
it was if you can have nice bread enjoy
it and I had a piece of bread and it
didn't mess with me and I was so like
shocked and I still have the habit of
not eating anything any of that stuff
usually but but having this one piece of
bread and it was like this experience
and I don't feel compelled to eat it
every single day still in fact I feel
compelled not to eat it every day so
that if I do decide you know once a
month or something to have a piece of
bread I can truly enjoy it and maybe
even have something to look forward to
let's see here past life experience asks
how necessary are most supplements
depends on doesn't it magnesium what do
we know about magnesium it's important
for everything and everybody is
deficient yeah it's like I take a
magnesium supplement supplement that you
all prescribed to me subscribe but I
don't know you you you you recommend
yeah there you go
and I still take it a night like before
you know before going to bed and I know
that that is part of just my regular
supplementation but I'm certainly not
taking 112 pills a day now but there was
a time where that was that was important
for what I was trying to accomplish and
then glycine is another one how many
people are getting enough glycine yeah
what does go so let's talk about
magnesium let's talk about glycine one
of those so magnesium is it's a nutrient
element so like sodium you've probably
heard from of from salt or calcium it's
on the periodic table it's technically a
metal it's important for a whole host of
things including how your nerves
function how you produce ATP in the
mitochondria it's important for some of
the enzymes that do that and it's you
know very important for things like
pressure cardiovascular disease risk and
you know we know there's been a couple
of review papers that came out recently
one by Steven genuis we mentioned
earlier the the the detox guy and then
another one by James de nickel Antonio
who's been doing a lot of work showing
us that restricting salt intake is
probably for most people gonna be
harmful rather than beneficial it's all
the other stuff in your diet that's the
issue it's not the salt um and actually
there's a whole host even though it's
actually very hard to measure magnesium
and detect a true magnesium deficiency
but if you sort of really dig into it
you can safely make the assumption that
most of us are deficient and adding some
back in taking a supplement is you know
is very low risk with high potential
rewards so that kind of thing and can be
very can be very beneficial a glycine
there's another one that's it's an amino
acid so one of the building blocks of
proteins but it doesn't tend to be in
the protein sources that most of us eat
nowadays like it's not in huge contents
in plant proteins so that there is some
and it's not really in muscle meats so
if we're eating say steak you don't
really get much glycine and there's some
really important stuff about the balance
of different amino acids in terms of how
you then do all kinds of other metabolic
reactions in the body so particularly
methylation reactions of people might
have heard of methylation methylation
being an issue that some people have and
glycine is very important in that
pathway and others it's very it's mainly
important for making connected tissue if
your in terms of the building blocks but
in order to get those building blocks
you need to eat connective tissue and
how often do we eat skin and bones and
cartilage and stuff like that we just
don't traditionally we may have done
that we don't do that anymore so that
way you have doing collagen with ascent
glycine yeah okay okay so so I'm taking
it without even knowing I'm taking yeah
yeah outsource that kind of stuff yeah
yeah but you can do I mean so if you're
listening to this and you don't to spend
a lot of money on a glycine supplement
then you can just eat them eat the whole
animal right a nose-to-tail make bone
broth right a lot of butchers consider
that stuff waste product so you get it
super cheap the bones sometimes we'll
have noticed some butchers are kind of
cutting on now that they realize they
can sell the bones for money whereas
before they would give them away
yeah the market works that way yeah so
you roast the bones and then just drop
them in some water if you've got an
insta pot which is a pressure
you can get from Amazon you can do bone
broth in 90 minutes and then it's this
rich latinus soup and it's rich in
glycine so if you don't want to take a
supplement you can you can certainly
make it for yourself yes so any meat
that's cut you know they're like the
tough membrane and the stuff in the
joints like oh that's that's where
you're gonna get it skin so skiing or
chicken or you know any other animal
hasn't will have a good amount of glass
in it so yeah you don't have to buy the
supplements and I guess this is goes to
the main point which is that if you
manage to get if you're in good health
and you manage to get all your ducks in
a row in terms of maybe giving your body
the nutrients is going to need from the
diet most supplements are absolutely not
necessary at all yeah yeah and one thing
that I saw them in would tolerate organ
meat yet yeah if you had it as a kid so
my my wife actually ate a lot of organ
meat when she was pregnant in the second
half of pregnancy when she got after
over the morning sickness and IV just
came out loving organ me and she only
eats you asked for the us wellness meats
liverwurst in branch water
have you tried that the us they do
awesome like they're kind of fresh meat
sausages which have a lot of liver and
some heart and stuff in them and they've
got they're really good and they don't
taste they don't taste like awful I'll
give that because right now I just been
doing I do like beef liver pills or
whichever one do you recommend yeah
that's another way you do it I think
that the u.s. Wellness meets the this
breakfast sausages are really good they
taste us like like deli meat real mocha
I'll give it a shot for sure I'm at a
point now where meat doesn't isn't just
roll yeah of course I mean I do get that
when I was the same I I was only eating
fish in like the idea but that was kind
of the deal I made with myself actually
was if I was gonna eat me then I would
eat the whole animal yeah rather than
just I mean what we basically what we do
is we take a cow and we just rip bits
off of its legs and just eat that right
and the rest of it goes in the trash you
mind them there's a farm down the road
from us in Bonnie Doon we asked them if
we could have the organ meat and they
said no we're not allowed to sell you
that it has to go to like some freakin
disposal visually generative it's
absolutely bonkers like that's the best
bit that's the only bit I can't get and
if you again if you go to traditional
cultures where you know we kind of feel
like we can be informed by some of those
people who are still living off the land
you know how would they eat if they're
having to you know either farm that just
their own animals or then you know get
plants out of the we know whatever
wilderness is around them and you know
so cattle herders please everything
about the Maasai tribe you know they
drink the blood and they eat the organs
and in those kinds of sizes the dogs get
the steak right that's that's not the
intestines that you know that all those
other bits that we just won't eat that's
what is prized in those cultures and
obviously you know and so you're eating
the inside of the guts of this animal
that was just killed and it's gonna be
full of those bugs and probiotics and
all that kind of stuff and that's the
stuff that we just don't we don't really
eat anymore so if you're not gonna eat
those things and then you know maybe
some supplements but it become important
but you certainly can do it yeah
yeah I think that that the key is making
sure you're getting the nutrition you
need and then you can supple yeah start
now is a book and an approach with some
irritation
we are always ideally get to people get
people to a point where they don't need
supplements but sometimes you just can't
do it for whatever reason and sometimes
you you're not absorbing things properly
and you just you've been in a bad enough
place that you could never get back to
100% so if that means you have to take a
little bit of magnesium and a little bit
of glycine ah you know I think that's
okay
yeah yeah I think is potential downsides
are quite small right the main one being
financial there's very few supplements
that you're going to cause a problem
I mean I suppose if you just supplement
with a ton of zinc by itself or iron
when you didn't need it it means or a
load of its activity right you can
overdo it but generally you just create
expensive P whereas the problems
associated with the nutritional
deficiency of devastating so I mean
personally I'd rather go the first
option sure and there are some
supplement companies that are better
than others I mean often we have thorne
supplements because they're the most
similar to they have the rigorous yeah
they've got really good scientists and
doctors on their team who choose the
most bioavailable forms of all of the
micronutrients and then another thing we
love with them especially working with
athletes who get tested is they do they
use the similar technology that we use
when we're testing new the human they
test use that same technology to test
the supplements to make sure that it is
what they think it is right so you know
maybe your pea protein has got cadmium
in it unless it's definitely plausible
and I think it probably has been found
and so they're making sure that's not
happening by testing the supplement it
goes into quarantine when it first
arrives and then they do they test it
two more times as it's going through
production so that the standard of care
the quality is very very high and you
pay for it but you also know you know
what you're getting creatine is another
one there oh yeah that's a crazy I mean
if you'd especially if you're an athlete
like this not really much of a reason
not to take creatine now is there yeah I
think I take one scoober is that five
milligrams five grams okay yeah five
grams one teaspoon it's probably if it's
like a teaspoon or a group of five mils
scoop it's probably like two to three
grams
I was just plenty for that for the
average person it's I mean most people
could probably benefit from from some
creatine wiser again so it goes back to
it it goes back largely to methylation
so producing creatine is one of the most
methylation heavy processes in the body
and basically what creatine does is it's
a it's a buffer for very very rapid
energy usage particularly the muscles
but it's also important in the brain and
other parts of the body and so that's
you know that when you do something very
very fast
the first offloading of energy comes
from creatine and so it's just like it's
basically an energy buffer in the body
but the the it's very intense very
methylation and metabolically intensive
to
reduce it and so and people who eat a
lot of meat if you eat you know a pound
a pound or two of beef a day you
probably get you know around one to two
grams of creatine that's probably enough
of people aren't eating that much red
meat then they can usually benefit from
supplementation it's the most heavily
researched supplement in terms of sports
performance and particularly in
weightlifting or sprinting activities
but you don't want the big sugary
creatine you know yeah a lot of people
in fact it's so cheap now nobody's
making crap creatine because it's it's
to Sochi so actually you can still buy a
crab curry I mean you walk walk past all
the way by is it sick a towel no this is
this is this the one important thing
about creatine so I was going off on my
tangent about creatine but by is called
creapure creatine monohydrate it's made
in Germany and so basically all the
creatine that you buy is is is usually
just white labeled Korea people they buy
in bulk in Germany and then they put
their sticker on it that is what you
want if it's not creapure it's basically
made in some industrial state in in
China and Lord knows what's in there so
yeah so you can trust the thorn one
other one can trust
I thought the Korea pure was so cheap
that it wasn't worth anyone ya know you
can still find ones that aren't and what
creep your is so cheap but you can still
find ones that have examined calm it's a
great resource actually thinking about
it they've got all if you want to see
all the scientific references on
creatine then examine calm it's a
fantastic resource or any supplement for
that matter and I still take like the
thorn am/pm sort of multi vitamin D is
that yeah so so that's just your general
multivitamin and then the bio just mmm
that's sports and legends of enzymes and
some so basically for people you have
had chronic gut issues breaking down and
absorbing nutrients is often still an
issue because the body needs to produce
those and when all of your systems have
been struggling that's just one of the
things that gets shut down is is
producing those enzymes and
it's one of those things where you know
haven't done hundreds of big studies on
them because nobody gonna make any money
out of settings are just of enzymes but
a lot of people seem to benefit
particularly early on as they're
supporting their gut just by taking some
digestive enzymes and again we work with
a lot of athletes and there there are
some good studies on supplementing
various enzymes and seeing improvements
in terms of recovery so there's there's
definitely enough to suggest that if you
you know you're really struggling with
digestion you like you get bloated after
you eat and you know obviously you might
have some deeper issue that you need to
treat it's the food side of things once
you fix the food side of things and if
there's something in the gut that needs
to be you know gotten rid of this
doesn't mean take biology and then eat
the pizza yeah that doesn't solve all
the problems sadly but it can certainly
help as you as you start to get that
stuff back online okay gotcha and I'm
trying to think if there's anything else
that I'm taking regularly but that
sounds right I do occasionally some fish
oil from thorn if I'm not eating
sardines at the time so I try to get it
through sardines first but then if I
don't I can supplement with with some
fish oil but that's just because so
sorry I mean that's literally what the
word means and the small fish sardines
have less time to bioaccumulate mercury
and so that's probably why they're
better than the huge fish they'd be down
a lot longer yeah for sure they don't
taste as good but it's its food as
medicine all right so that's actually a
good also a good source of collagen and
glycine if you get the the sardines they
come in a can with skin and bones yeah
well in it yeah well the playing well
plant ones are great all that stuff goes
in you you're getting all that stuff
with that again without using a whole
animal you're in a dream the whole lot I
buy them by the case on Amazon yeah
jerilyn they just got into that game
like I should have put more shares in
wild planet right yeah they but they do
it right and so in it's one of those
places that you can trust as opposed to
just go into in some parts the world
it's all that culture I was in Portugal
last summer and it's a quite I think
it's quite a deep part of their culture
and they actually have shops on the high
street and so nothing but sardines you
go in there and it's all these and it's
almost like ah you know that the cans
are all so beautifully painted and
there's so much care and attention has
gone into the shop it's it's obviously a
thing there and
somehow it's just not in our culture for
some reason for anybody who gets weirded
out by like oh my god skin and bones I
don't but you don't know you don't taste
it it's there there's no textural
component just kind of like dissolves in
the mouth you don't even you don't taste
it because the sardines kind of gross
and so everything else started most the
time when we work with people and they
say they don't like sardines that does
not have good sardine right right I
totally agree that in the wild plan once
I get the lemon ones with its lemon
olive oil and so like it's sort of
masked the flavor pleasure it's it's
high in fat too and so like it's better
than just getting like sardines that are
flopping around in water from like a
Costco I'm sorry yeah you know you don't
want that I once wrote an article for a
Florida Fitness website telling people
not to eat protein bars into it just see
a tin of soybeans instead because like
if you eat a low carb protein bar like
the the nutrition that you get in terms
of protein and fats life is almost
identical to a tin of sardines but
obviously there's all this other good
stuff in there like got loads of my
people like you're asking people to eat
sardines after the gym it's super weird
but that's what I would yeah well I
agree with you and by the way I think
that's just a good rule of thumb anyway
it's like if it comes in a package is
probably not worth eating and in the
first place right and so I think that
this is we can wrap up the supplement
discussion with the best supplementation
is food and then if you can't get it
from food then all the stuff we talked
about you can actually supplement the
food that you're eating this one tricky
one of two still awkward what's
important that's vitamin k2 like how
does someone that doesn't eat that weird
Japanese natto
what does k2 is that in the multivitamin
it's it's a one of the fat soluble
vitamins that basically tells your body
it does a number of things but it it's
mainly largely important in terms of
telling your body where calcium should
go so like vitamin D is very important
for like strong bones and all that kind
of not putting calcium in your arteries
which can cause a heart attack sort of
but there it comes from liver and eggs
and then the the most concentrated and
send some cheese but the most
concentrated source is Chinese is
Japanese fermented soy beans called
natto okay which is really is it's I
mean you talked about not like in
sardines natto is not good
like it's it's hard if it's not been
part of your culture to eat it it's hard
to eat so sometimes so I mean if you're
eating two or three pastured eggs a day
you're probably getting enough k2 but if
you're not say yeah yeah I mean because
there's a there's a big study done in
Holland I think we showed that you
basically need like 15 to 30 micrograms
a day it's not very much okay but most
people if you're just eating a highly
refined standard American diet you're
not getting enough k2 gotcha
well I was gonna also mention probiotics
but I think the next question here is
from April April is what are the best
things you can do on a daily basis to
maintain good gut health so this is I
mean this is almost like a buzzword
right we hear gut health and like I'm
seeing on all the products and and I'd
see it on Cheerios now good gut health I
mean I don't know it's actually I
wouldn't be surprised if that's what
they so I think we have to be a bit
cautious too and when we talk about good
gut health one of the things that I
think most expensive thing the
supplement that I have has to do with
the probiotic yeah refrigerated
probiotics yeah so can we talk a bit
about probiotics and when they're
necessary when they aren't yeah sure I
mean so arts the original question I
think the best thing you can do for your
gut health on an ongoing basis without
spending a fortune on probiotics is to
eat a wide variety of vegetables and
what about fermented foods
yeah fermented foods I mean what do you
think Tommy yeah I mean so the kimchi
you know it's I think it's interesting
again that most cultures have had some
kind of access to a fermented food you
know you need a food to last longer than
you have it for then there's some kind
of fermentation process and you know
when you put from it like fermented food
or a probiotic so these are bacteria
you're putting in your mouth they don't
really go into the gut and set up shop
they don't then become the bacteria in
the gut but they do seem to help some
processes along it's just we're used to
being exposed to these things and they
can have some beneficial effects but
this certainly doesn't need to be you
know come in a supplemental form so yes
some fermented foods are great they're
not a sin
you're eating a wide variety of foods be
they plants be they you know so actually
you can get some some of those
prebiotics which feeds the gut bacteria
from from like the collagen and all that
you know the bones and having fiber
animal fiber you might call it so so so
basically and anything like that which
sort of can feed so you're not bacteria
in on the food you're trying to give the
bacteria what it needs in order to be
able to grow and survive and thrive okay
and I mean the caveat with that is that
if you're somebody who's had gut issues
for a long period of time or you have
some kind of overgrowth we've taken
antibiotics and you've fostered some
kind of some kind of issue there then
those are the exact foods they're going
to be trigger foods for you you know
those wide variety of fibers and then
you might need to try something called
well you might need to do some testing
you might need to try something called a
low fodmap diet which basically he
removes those fibers you may even need
to go even further and do like an
elemental diet which basically takes out
anything that the bacteria in the gut
can ferment and then you build back up
right it's not a long-term thing you do
that to try and starve down a population
of bacteria that's causing an issue and
then the corner of our diet helps people
with issues occurs you have to look in
some extreme cases like an extreme IBS
I've seen people talking about where
they've removed essentially all fiber in
order to fix which it's counterintuitive
at first so you want fiber to you know
clear you out but the fiber is actually
the thing that's there's giving you the
problem and it's interacting with the
gut in a weird way and by sort of
depriving yourself maybe at least
temporarily maybe it gives the the gut
time to sort of work it out yeah there's
actually interestingly very little
evidence that adding fiber to the diet
causes any real benefit which is again
one of the contrary to one of the things
that we've we've often been told and in
one specific scenario which is IBS
irritable bowel syndrome and in
constipation actually taking out fiber
seems to seems to be beneficial and
again doesn't need to be a long-term
thing but that could that's definitely
where some people are seeing benefit on
something like a carnivore type diet
where they're taking out all plants and
all the fiber associated with them and
it kind of makes sense so if you imagine
a tube that's blocked up the answer to
that problem isn't stuffing more stuff
into the tube because that's just gonna
cause more of a blockage right and this
is all these uh in my head like I'm so
when I first came to you I had all kinds
like there would be days I wouldn't go
to the bathroom for like three or four
days sometime yeah I mean I think yes
another way you get rid of toxic yeah I
would pee just fine but like I was just
not pooping just a regular basis was not
happening and then I changed a few
things and my diet just by default we
were removing some fibers from my diet
because I was eating more meat so my
calories were coming from more protein
and fat right and things started moving
and now I go every single day and often
twice a day and that is one of the
largest improvements I don't have the
terrible gut pain when I came to you
guys like I just knew like regularly I'm
just gonna every time I eat I'm just
gonna be in pain for a few hours yeah
it's not under eating actually it's when
they feel like that right and I I didn't
I didn't know III I didn't know what to
do
and then I when I came to you guys we
started working together it's sort of by
default we remove some of the excess
fibers like I didn't realize like how
much an Apple would just mess me up
which you wouldn't think people often
yeah apple a day keeps the doctor no it
just kept me from going to the bathroom
that was the problem and that's what was
appropriate for me and eating more more
meat actually helped solve a lot of the
gut problems I was having mixed with the
probiotics and all the other things that
we did to help fix the gut so now that I
do have good gut health what sounds like
what I do now is wide variety of foods
you know vegetables and natural foods
your real foods I should say and none of
the processed stuff and then if I want
to supplement a bit with sauerkraut or
kimchi or kombucha occasionally then
those things don't hurt at all right it
may even help a little bit yeah right
it's confusing because you know the
thing that's going to help you in the
beginning is not necessarily the same
thing that's going to help you in the
long term another thing that's going to
help you in the long term may be
detrimental
right at the start if you're gonna try
and eat like that immediately back then
you would have felt tuck you know lots
of kimchi and fermented loads of fiber
you would have felt terrible but now it
makes you feel good and it helps so it's
just the the appropriate thing at the
appropriate time is that you know so
it's sadly not an easy answer what do
you think we talked about putting the
fire out first yes before rebuilding the
house but now I don't want to go and
like take a fire extinguisher to my
walls it wouldn't make any sense to do
that now and so yeah it's it's what's
the appropriate time and this is in the
the I don't know a whole lot about this
but I hear this also is a buzzword so
Don asks can you talk about candida
overgrowth and its symptoms and the
natural methods of eliminating it so I I
assume this is often related to our
extreme intake of sugar and and yeah I
guess sugars right can you talk about
Candida and why it's become a pop
culture phenomenon recently yeah it
certainly can be and so and the the the
sugar aspect to it may well be part of
it and we talked about I said this is it
might be what is candy as a yeast ox I
might call it yeast overgrowth that's
nothing and you might recognize Candida
because it can cause thrush so you know
rashes in the the genital area has often
caused by the same the same yeast and
the symptoms are wide and varied and
it's you know we tend to see it quite
quite frequently and we pick it up as a
metabolite of the yeast in the urine
that's where that's how that's how we
pick it up and so a while back Chris
actually built some machine learning
algorithms to try and predict
biochemical problems so things you might
see in the guts or in hormones or in the
blood based on just the responses to
some question and like a standard
question I people come in they answer 50
questions and they just say you know
that you know how well do you sleep you
know not very well or very well or you
know how lowly do you feel or you know
do you feel that you're a part of a
group of friends and you say like not
very much or very much so it's basically
you're looking on a scale of one to five
and one of the things that predicts a
yeast overgrowth is is sugar cravings or
you know feeling cravings for sugar so
we're
previously that was kind of like one of
those things where we were like oh we're
not really sure if that's the case at
least from our data from the people that
we work with that certainly seems to be
the case that it was predictive of a
yeast overgrowth and it can be
associated with all those other things
so we talked about brain fog or systemic
inflammation I can produce something
called oxalate which can then like do
funny things with the minerals in your
body may be associated with things like
joint pain and maybe with kidney stones
a bit sort of depending on who you are
that the symptoms can be varied if you
do have a test with and/or you can see
on a stool test - if you have a load of
yeast that just turns up in your poop
you know that's probably a bad sign
yeah and again just like the bacteria in
the gut you will have some yeast and
your gut that's very normal
it's just when they start to sort of
take over or feel an itch that's theirs
but the other bacteria have left because
they've been killed with antibiotics or
something
mm-hmm and then and this is actually one
of the cornerstones of the things that
Chris started doing with his clients um
so maybe you can talk about it but some
some herbal protocols can can usually be
very effective it's gonna say you asked
a question about probiotics earlier then
this might be I mean so that's when we
use them is with a specific application
in mind I don't take a probiotic for no
reason just as like I take the
multivitamin it's for a specific
application and so sacrum Isis Berardi
actually I think there's some some
evidence for that as another use which
is another he stay running and it's not
coming along and setting up shop it's
just temporarily creating an environment
that's not conducive towards Candida and
then it's gone the whole lot of them are
gone and actually it's there's some
evidence to show that it's helpful with
overgrowth of seed if as well that's why
I was taking yeah exactly it's super
high doses like sometimes people say oh
yeah I took one capsule that didn't do
anything you were taking like how many
capsules a day at the beginning well no
I was doing the powder stuff oh that's
that that's a different one
they said yeah I'm pretty sure you did
at the beginning as a long time I was
every year ago oh yeah okay like 16
capsules a day or something it was it
was quite a bit yeah then some so we
often use some herbal protocols so
Oregon Oh or oregano dried in works
great our DDO biocide in which is a it's
like a tincture of various different
Hubbs there's also something called
under 'selenic acid or SF 72 which also
has some Laura sided loris item which is
derived from coconut so there's there's
there's quite a few things that can work
against the yeast overgrowth but again
find the thing that caused that problem
in the first beast doesn't just show up
in some kind of so are you maybe know
compromised or have you done some kind
of damage to your gut so there's some
really interesting work that basically
shows that once you have you've set up
an inflammatory process in the gut you
start to feed a whole different set of
bacteria there are some bacteria that
work really well in that environment in
there were the some that don't so is
there something else that's causing an
issue in the gut which then or you know
causing an issue with your immune system
which then allows the candida to set up
shop you know there's always going to be
a layer beneath it so start by thinking
about and again it comes back to diet
and environment and stress and all those
other things try and figure that out and
then usually eradicate in the East
itself it is in most people it is fairly
easy okay so do you have a terrible time
with it with the athletes so I mean
we're wondering whether over exercising
their sizes problems actually causing
the inflammatory environment in the gut
and then the bifida bacteria goes away
and then Candida maybe ever grows it's
just kind of you know at the moment but
we do see a lot in our athletes okay so
so in the case of an athlete maybe
reducing the amount of yeah but you're
never gonna get them studio I know
just take them on a lure at that point
right like okay we did a reasonable
investigation and we got as far as we
could and now in us need to make a
decision and you know yeah I don't you
know so I mean you know we have some
guys who the the sport pays the bills
right here if you're a pure Olympian to
say Zelly if you're if you're an
Olympian or you're a professional
athlete and that's wonder I don't know
you can't you just can't you can't do
they can't say oh well one you just
stopped training right then it's like
well why don't you stop paying your
mortgage it just doesn't make any sense
so I already went to the doctor and you
already told me to stop exercise I think
that's why I'm here
so then you get to a point where you
know maybe maybe appreciate that during
hard periods of training you're gonna
develop some kind of issues of the guts
so you just cycle through you know you
take some organic or you take some
similar aside
or something and it just sort of keeps
things under control and then during the
off-season your gut settles out and it's
just it has to be part of your protocol
as an athlete just because that's that's
the nature of the game got you all right
we got let's see we have two more
questions I want to save them for the
PostScript episode so these questions
have to do with sadness depression
overwhelm despair and other emotions and
also anxiety so each week we record a
postscript episode for our patreon
supporters so if you all want to listen
to that you can go over to the
minimalists comm slash support will do a
quick PostScript episode but before we
we finish this up here there are a few
other words here that then we probably
didn't get to we talked about toxins we
talked about immune system we talked we
talked a little bit about hormones so
anything else that we should maybe talk
about I don't one thing that you told me
Chris was hey we do we test for for guys
like testosterone has always went there
how can I increase my testosterone and I
did have I had low testosterone when we
first tested it and now I have moderate
but it's on the low side of moderate I
think there's a way you probably
described it was 502 or so you're well
within what we would call the normal
range but you're just outside what I
like the ideal ideal you know obviously
enough of an increase to see to see the
benefit yeah I don't know roar was
originally but it was well below that
and we've done several tests since then
but and it's improved incrementally but
also improvement doesn't necessarily
mean like well I need to get this to 800
right I want to have like I mean there's
there's a term roid-rage where someone
is just like totally you know that
they're full of testosterone and you all
sent me some studies that were
fascinating about the the increase in
crime for people with high I don't think
it's a normal physiological levels of
testosterone don't don't cause that type
of behavior right when you talk about
roid rage you're talking about exogenous
testosterone and it just modulates an
existing behavior rather than causing it
to begin with there's some really
interesting stuff around it increases
the likelihood that a behavior could a
behavior that you might have a
propensity to do anyway
might increase the likelihood that that
that will happen and if anybody's
interested in this stuff you should read
behave by Robert we have to mentioned
him he's one of our you know he's heroes
yeah absolutely
what a link to all these books in the
shownotes people can dive in deep but
yeah so I guess so the main the main so
the main thing that testosterone can do
is it switches off the prefrontal cortex
which is like where your deliberation
and your it's your filter right so it
switches off it can switch off the
filter and it's not like you know if you
if you take testosterone all of a sudden
you become an [ __ ] it's like it it
makes certain things more likely to
happen but the main the main summary is
that more isn't necessarily better right
you need enough for all those processes
to happen what a metaphor for life as we
call it enough is 'm and ya you need you
need enough testosterone but you know
we've had people who are like i'm gonna
be fixed and feel great when my
testosterone reaches a thousand and
that's it's just not true like there's
there's there's nothing that's gonna
change when your testosterone goes from
seven hundred to a thousand because you
already have enough that to do all the
things that you need to do so like and
again it goes back to the test results
you know you can fund you can fetishize
a number and we do see quite a lot of
that but in reality the subjects you
experience is much more important yeah
do you have any symptoms of low
testosterone and if you don't then great
tip you know job done we don't need to
worry about but if you have low libido
or sex drive in fact there were some
questions that you asked me early on I
had that I had to do some serious
rumination about it you rely you talked
about why are you attracted to your
partner right and I think that that's
one thing because I was in a long
marriage and I know like eventually we
totally grew apart and there was a
problem there and it didn't have
anything to do with hormones at the time
it was my mid 20s and and it just had to
do that we grew apart and like no I
don't think we were attracted to each
other anymore like we were really good
roommates
and in fact we still we get a long way
better now than we ever did when I
married she has you know a great family
now and we can talk and like we have a
good friendship but we we weren't and
and so you asked me that question and
I had to like really step back and think
like and the answer was yeah I'm crazy
attract attracted the blacks and like
it's it's proven out in the physiology
now but there was a period of time where
yeah I mean it was like well if I could
just fix my testosterone but that's kind
of like saying what if I bought the
third BMW then I'll be happy you know if
some of the seven hundred testosterone
they're trying to get to a thousand and
it's like okay but why why are you
trying to do this and I think it's the
same thing we look at our material
possessions or we look at our health
like what are the symptoms what are you
trying to fix here and I think sometimes
we don't know we just we chase after a
number or a thing or a status or a
number of followers or whatever right
without the thing of why we're doing
this right and it's this goal this trap
of constant horizon seeking I hear that
a lot from from clients oh I'll be happy
when I lose another ten pounds I'll be
happy when my total testosterone is 700
I'll be happy where and of course as
soon as you get to 700 or 10 pounds
light or whatever it is that's the next
horizon becomes and then then you just
chasing your tail forever yeah yeah and
being being happy with enough is like is
like the the that's what minimalism is
for me it's the it's the art of having
enough I figure out what enough is for
me because there was a there was a point
where I didn't have an appropriate
amount my hormones were out of whack and
it calls low libido it caused all these
problems and and now the other nice
thing is my partner and I both have
really similar libidos and I think
that's that's one thing if you're
dealing with someone else who who your
significant other you're looking for a
partner like finding someone with with a
libido that matches yours is is
something that is like really gratifying
because you know I'm not trying to have
sex 14 times a day but but but I also
have the desire to have sex with the
person I'm with and it makes for a
really fulfilling relationship so you
asked me some really hard questions we
first when we first talked because I
have to reveal that most as I saw it
questions with tommays this is the way
that we operate at nourish balance
thrive is that we have this team of
people and you know we get together and
it's
a scrum is an appropriate word as we
said the agile tech not we use a system
of dividing conflict conquer to get
stuff done with our clients and they
have this part of it is the scrum and
it's a metaphor for you know when you
throw the ball into the the scrimmage
underneath you spike it's a bit like
that so we back things around and yeah
quite often one of us health coaches
will then go up and have that go on and
have that hard conversation with the
client and its really here this asking
all these hard questions well you get to
ask all the hard question yeah after
actually break eye contact Roxy yeah so
it's great because we can talk about so
if somebody has low libido or erectile
dysfunction I can say Chris well ask him
whether whether he finds his partner
attractive but asking whether he's
masturbating to pornography
you know I'll sum all these other things
I don't have to do it Chris does yeah I
mean the answers there the thing that's
like important like if if you're used to
a level of weirdness that's only
obtainable from pornography good luck
trying to get turned on when your
experience will real life is like a
thankfully vex gets really weird so
we're good in that department yeah yeah
yeah we can we can replicate a lot of
what's on the Internet
let's see what else we have here skin
and acne we kind of talked about you
mean you mentioned it with with thrush
uh-uh that that's one type of like that
that's I don't know if you'd categorize
that as an autoimmune response but but
there are a lot of other like eczema or
acne or one of the other ones that that
I mean the skin lard largest organ in
the body we didn't have a lot of
problems with it I know if I eat dairy I
break out and figuring that out just
allowed me to cut dairy out of my diet
know how few people figure that out by
the way like I think a lot how many
young women are eating dairy today and
ending up with terrible acne and just
and not and then they do exactly what
you do you go to the doctor and they get
they prescribed antibiotics for the acne
right yeah well and that's the other
thing man I so and I don't know if
they'll be the long-term effects of this
we'll see but uh accutane was one thing
that I took for several years way longer
than the normal rounds people usually
take and he put same doctor who gave me
the back Trent put me on a fairly benign
dose of a key
my lips are bleeding but didn't have any
acne and and so yeah we want the magic
pill as opposed I didn't know man I mean
if you would have just said hey yeah
that's because you're eating dairy and
by the way you have this weird soy
allergy that most people don't have but
you do and it makes your head break out
if you stop eating that or I can't tell
you how that for sure but why don't you
try eliminating it for 30 days I mean
the problem is that most people have an
emotional attachment to food that you
obviously don't and I'm the same as you
I don't have emotional attachments to
food but people definitely have an
emotional attachment to cheese yeah my
partner she's from Minnesota and when
school Wisconsin alt you could ever get
her some is she she functions fine she
thrives on cheese everything's fine with
her right
but in our five-year-old I mean you try
to take you have to pull the cheese out
of her dead hands but thankfully they're
fine on it right and but I think we have
to realize that well if we have skin
problems then its profit it's caused by
what we're putting into our body not
always but quite often yeah it's and so
a lot of skin issues seem like again we
go back to the gut
so rosacea something that people often
like reddening or changing of the skin
on the face though that's that's very
seems to be well connected to a small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth so again
just a dysbiosis or an imbalance of the
bacteria in the gut certain again also
immune skin conditions a allergies so
ex-mo as part of that kind of with
seasonal allergies and asthma sort of
like a2p we call that which is just sort
of being allergic to a lot of different
stuff and that can also be associated
with gut issues acne as seems to be you
know problems with so people who have
very high levels of insulin have a lot
of kin that can contribute to acne so
dairy we know particularly milk is great
increasing insulin so so milk is often a
big issue and then also refined
carbohydrates you know large glucose
spikes large insulin spikes that seems
to be of course a problem for people
with acne so again
I was like covered in it when I was
eating yeah yeah well went away when I
took and we hear that all the time so
people don't come to us necessarily to
fix skin issues but you're like you fix
that diet they're like oh my god my skin
is amazing they just didn't even realize
that it was a problem and until they
started eating better yeah and that's
the thing like mine got so bad in my
early 20s that I finally went to a
dermatologist who provided all these
solutions right and and all I had to do
was change a few things in my own my own
life and my diet and I would have
radically improved all these these these
problems that I had and I think I think
the the key is like be willing to
experiment be willing to eliminate some
stuff and see what happens if you
eliminate something for 30 days and all
of a sudden your skin gets better then
great maybe you don't bring it back in
or if you do bring it back in a
miniscule level yeah every once while he
said maybe you eat a piece of cake every
once in a while but it's no longer that
glass of milk with with next to the
glass of orange juice for breakfast
right yeah all right what else do I have
here
Oh what are you worried your thoughts on
alcohol and coffee both can but both can
be but I limit myself I do three cups a
day now I now in the corporate world
full disclosure here
I worked 80 hours a week and I did I
probably had 20 cups of coffee a day oh
wow and I and I of course I was like the
[ __ ] coffee too so I'd put like dairy
and and Splenda that was all yeah and so
like I'm just like take it that's not
even that's not just coffee either but
but if I saw I drink two or three cups
of coffee a day and I always get these
this conflict' and it's black coffee and
it's really good coffee but I get
conflicting sort of advice and reports
back on that yes so if you're again so
it kind of depends and there's multiple
ways to look at it so coffee has been
shown to all be associated so it they
haven't done like randomized control
trials but if you look at PD Mia
logically
associated with a number of benefits in
terms of reduced risk of strokes and
diabetes and Alzheimer's disease and all
that kind of stuff and and actually some
of those benefits even com if you're
drinking decaf coffee because it's so
some of the some of the like phenolic
compounds that are in the coffee rather
than the caffeine itself people who may
or may not benefit from from from CAF
the caffeine itself is to do with how
well you metabolize caffeine you can
actually you can actually measure that
if you're worried about it so you know
some people just metabolize caffeine
really slowly it really affects them you
know that's my partner so yeah the
23andme thing yeah and then you'd say
who do we send that off to um I forget
Ben Lynch strategies yes yes and and
yeah I metabolize caffeine very quickly
she metabolize it really slowly so she
can't have anything after like 7:00 a.m.
or she's screwed later later tonight so
that's that's part of it I used to dress
so I drink a lot of coffee probably 50
to 75% of what I drink is decaf Swiss
water process decaf cuz I just like I
like the coffee that my first cup in the
morning has caffeine and then after that
because I used to think caffeine doesn't
affect me and then I was like well do
you know what maybe I'll see if I notice
whether I sleep better and I do if I
don't have if I post my cat Coffee is
decaffeinated then I definitely sleep
out in the evening so that's you might
it's the same with loads of things that
you exposed to you like oh yeah that
doesn't bother me
until you remove it you don't notice the
effect that it actually has and the
Swiss water processes is the thing that
you're talking about that is important
here just knowing a little bit about
coffee Ryan and I own a coffee shop down
in st. Pete and a roaster and quite
often the decaf beans that you buy you
know if you go buy Folgers decaf at your
local Walmart it's just the worst of the
worst beans and then the the process of
decaffeinated them basically is is it's
a chemical process so they throw a bunch
of chemicals on there and what you're
talking about Swiss water process is a
natural way to D to remove the vast
majority of case decaffeinated doesn't
mean no caffeine it means a radically
reduced that your average cup goes from
100 milligrams to maybe 500 grams Kathy
yes most of there's a lot of organic
solvents so if you imagine like
tipping your beans in like paint
stripper and then and then right so
that's essentially I mean a lot of that
stuff evaporates because it's very
volatile but still you know not not
ideal so as splendid yeah
so I think does that cover all your
coffee questions yeah I think so that
now let's let's talk about alcohol
I don't drink personally yeah but then
you always hear these this conflicting
information one glass of red wine
you know increases was very troll or
water so the interesting thing about
resveratrol so again resveratrol was
gonna be the anti-aging compound that is
making every live forever they recently
did a study using high doses of
resveratrol in people with type 2
diabetes and actually in those in the
high group high dose group actually got
worse so it's not the miracle drug that
we once thought it was but actually to
get that kind of resveratrol from why
you need to drink like 20 gallons a day
or something so that's definitely not
alright every day that's not why
that's not why alcohol can be beneficial
and so again if you look at studies of
people and you ask them how much they
drink then you follow them over time
those are drink a small amount so on
average one to do one to two drinks a
day or on average around one drink a day
they do seem to you know have lower
disease risk live longer there's
multiple parts of that if you're sick
you're less likely to drink so you
automatically stack the deck against
those who aren't drinking and then you
know there's there's also the obviously
if you drink a lot that's and most
people who drink drink too much and
that's associated with a whole host of
other issues however again going back to
the coffee the same the same with the
alcohol if it's a small amount and
you're enjoying it and you're enjoying
it with others and it's a it's a process
of socialization and that nice glass of
red wine means that you're with friends
and having good conversation and all
that stuff then that's great is that one
glass of wine going to make you
healthier but who knows but it's
probably is it's certainly not as Pro
it's certainly not gonna be detrimental
at least for most people and then the
the the sort of the the setting and all
that you know can can be beneficial so
again a small amount is absolutely fine
we have no reason to think that it's
going to be detrimental
you know there's if it's you get home
after work and you're by yourself in
front of the TV drinking a beer I'm
again so like you you can do it better
and I think that's kind of that's how
you should think about it so it can be
fine it's likely has few if any health
benefits and obviously drinking too much
has a wholesome male but there may well
be there may well be a small health
benefit the problem is that it's very
difficult to find that signal because of
light like I mentioned previously those
who don't drink there are lots of other
reasons why they don't drink so then
when you see like the curve of amount
drunk versus health you it's very
difficult to pass out what's a true
benefit versus what's like just a
statistical anomaly based on who you're
sampling so there may be a small benefit
there may not be a benefit I would you
know if you're enjoying in as part of
like a bigger thing so I mean as I was
talking to a client just yesterday and
that you know she mentioned that she
hasn't been drinking but the but the
other day she was with her friends in
Italy they were by a lake and it was
sunny and she had half a glass of red
wine I was like great well that's the
play life you're gonna drink like that's
the perfect way to do it right you're
with your friends you're enjoying it
you're in the sunshine that's fine but
don't don't like go home and like chug a
glass of red wine so you think is gonna
make you live like I mean yeah Ryan I
thought so I we both have families who
struggle a lot with alcohol and drug
abuse both my parents were like extreme
alcoholics reason I've never touched a
drink in my life because they drank
enough for from my entire life as well
but no Ryan throughout his 20s and he's
talked about this before on the podcast
and in writing he would and actually in
our the next film we have coming out he
really he doesn't act a deep dive in
this but we we talk about he would go
home and have a case of beer a case
there's 24 K while sitting full I think
about six-pack no case and then you know
the go to the bar afterward and so like
there's obviously there's nothing
healthful about about that type of
experience but there are times what
sounds to me that we were saying is
there times where maybe it's social
lubrication one drink is not a bad thing
but also don't think it has the magical
benefits is gonna fix your life even
though
but again it's one that you know when
you sort of create a robust healthy
human then you know you can tolerate
more of these things that doesn't mean
you should holler you should force
yourself to tolerate them but right you
know in many of the people that we work
with you know cutting out alcohol
altogether to begin with is is very
important but then I think some of that
back in can certainly have benefits for
multiple reasons
can we talk about CBD and THC I mean we
both live in states where that's legal
now yeah and I can tell you I first
started doing CBD oil last year and just
to help out with with sleep I've heard
people talk about you it's good for back
pain and all this other stuff and I
found the curcumin is actually way way
better for back pain than the CBD oil
was for me ala but I haven't tried the
lotions and stuff like that but then
also THC and edibles especially like
Dole spray or like a vape pen before
going to bed I found that that helps me
out a little bit with sleep if I'm if
I'm struggling with sleep so I know
there are obvious upsides and downsides
I'd like to get some opinions on this we
have some data we don't even need it
yeah and we were we were actually
talking about this over breakfast that's
the kind of guys that we are yeah so the
interesting thing is that CBD on its own
based on the data that's available
should not help with sleep so basically
when they've looked at it and they've
given people CBD alone or CBD plus THC
the CBD alone can actually cause
alertness and it may be to do with how
CBD and THC affect cortisol metabolism
there's some other stuff of it you know
the the signal the ways they signal you
know so some people may sleep worse if
they take CBD and but when you add THC
then people seem to sleep better so
there's like there's a synergism there
however I can say for personal
experience that I've tried CBD alone
before bed and it certainly seems to
help it certainly does seem to help me
sleep and why that is I actually I
actually don't know I don't have a study
to say this is why I think there's the
you know there's gonna be an interaction
with all the other things that are going
on in the gut CBD has certainly been
shown or you know to improve got
information got health I don't think
that's an issue for me but
that's particularly animal studies and
now it's being translated to you know
CBD is now being used for in cancer
therapies and epileptics and they're
starting to use it in people with
inflammatory bowel disease so can
certainly have a number of benefits I
haven't tried the CBD plus THC THC was
more of a thing I did in my teenage
years but but have both been shown
potentially to help with sleep the the
potential downsides are obviously then
can interfere with cool summers hablas
and all this other stuff so if it's not
causing it if it's not causing you
benefit then you know there's no there's
potential downsides for taking it so I
mean we do think you know particularly
for people you know heavy marijuana uses
there is some risk of mental health
issues if that's coming from THC or
other things you know of it's obviously
the the strength the concentration of
THC in marijuana has increased
dramatically over the last few decades
so there's there's multiple factors that
play there if you're taking ten
milligrams of THC with 30 milligrams of
CBD before bed you know you're probably
well under that risk for sholde but
there are studies that show that it
interferes with hormone metabolism
called cell metabolism so it's just it's
at the moment is kind of a try it out
and see if it benefits you but equally
you know we roll back to our continuous
message which is why aren't you sleeping
in the first place right you don't want
to medicate yourself to sleep you want
to find out what it is it's causing your
poor sleep in the first place similar to
the melatonin supplements that can help
but but that is a band-aid off a
band-aid you not having enough melatonin
because you're exposing yourself to
bright lights and light all we know it's
something like that right and so I think
the micro dose for the few times where
I've done edibles where I get a like oh
I can't do anything else besides eat
potato chips today I just I don't like
the feeling and so I tend to I tend to
avoid avoid that but I also have found
the mental health thing so I have the
mental health problems running my family
my dad with schizophrenic
my brother was schizophrenic killed
himself and so I know like that's the
reason I won't do suicide but in other
things because there's a potential for
you know even though I think I'm well
past the age at this point where those
symptoms would present themselves I do
notice that the couple times where I've
tried that an edible that is like Oh
like this is too much the next day I
it's like the roller coaster there you
can't have the high without the low sort
of thing and the entire next day I'm
just like oh boy I should be happy right
now but I cannot be happy this is a
thing this is a story for anything that
you take to try and change the way your
brain functions what we usually say is
there's no biological free lunch right
you can't ask your brain to do something
which you wouldn't normally do and then
expect it to be completely normal after
so nootropics are a classic example you
know you take these compounds are
supposed to increase brain cognitive
function various brain functions but it
might increase function in one area but
it makes you less good in another area
and then some maybe well I will do I'll
take a nootropic use your book the only
time I do is before a podcast yeah and I
know in the afternoons I all I have this
crush yeah yeah there is a nootropic
crash for me I thought maybe I was
unique in that because I've never heard
anyone else talk about it but no I'm
certain if experience the same and there
are some some nootropics that are
basically just like the kitchen sink
everything's in there and this sort of
wire switches everything on you
definitely notice a difference but then
you gotta calm down later so I I often
likened it to taking MDMA where you
always switch everything on you feel
great and then you know a few hours
later you have this you have this big
come down and it's not the same for
everybody again it's something that you
have to experiment with yourself but but
you know again we go back to why isn't
your brain functioning as you would like
it to why do you feel the need to take
something to enhance your brain function
are there other things you could be
fixing and therefore you don't need to
stay that intro pic in the first place
you know that's always where we're gonna
go back to and then if you know
occasionally you need to try something
about you just need to be aware they're
asking your body or brain to do
something you wouldn't normally do you
might gonna you're gonna pay for it
later yeah either the THC thing is not
to a point where it's or at least that I
feel there's any sort of
psychoactive effect it's it's like micro
dosing that's like 1 or 2 milligram sort
of thing and the thing that helps me
with is with the sleep is it prolongs
the the period where I stay asleep
another thing that has really helped me
and I I've had to get really sort of
diligent about it and I screw up still
all the time water I drink a lot of
water during the day but I stop at 5:00
p.m. I stop drinking liquids of 5:00 and
that way I don't feel compelled to get
up at 3:30 a.m. to pee which but
sometimes when that happens I get up at
3:30 a.m. and I'm like I'm up I can't
get back to sleep now and so I found
those two things for me in the water is
probably way more helpful than than the
THC to be honest with you so just
something to think about any other words
about THC no it's not something they've
already interested me on the c-word site
about the stuff that's free like
sunshine I'm very excited about whereas
yeah sunshine deficiency can definitely
cause insomnia so like you can fix that
first before having to buy a supplement
we so we the one reason why we talk
about CBD is because again it might help
with people with inflamed guts and we
see a lot of those so we know a lot of
people who feel they've benefitted from
taking you for some see yeah so that's
an interesting thing that you bought up
recently is that maybe you have some
problem that's stopping you from
sleeping and then you take another thing
that makes that first problem worse and
maybe introduces another problem but the
net effect is still positive and so your
sleep does get better yeah ok that makes
sense where do we talk about here
meditation we won't really deal with
that I mean we all agree that it's a
good thing we probably don't do it
enough people that need it the most
please we've had Sam Harris on and and
Dan Harris especially and I fact I went
to the Sam Harris and Dan Harris event
recently and I suspect that Sam believes
that Dan isn't really meditating that's
what I end up getting from the event I
said have I said Dan attacks afterward
just kind of rib him but but I think
it's just we need different words like
with Sam thinks it was about a
meditation is you know after he spent
you know
seven years in India and caves basically
he learned how to meditate kind of thing
I'm exaggerating being a bit hyperbolic
but he's gone on three month meditation
silent meditation retreats and yeah yeah
which by the way it was and he's worn
some people against that like you could
have a serious mental breakdown too and
he acknowledges that you want to dip
your toe in the water before jumping all
the way and realizing you can't swim and
and Dan's prescription is that one
minute is meditating like if you can
it's better than zero minutes right and
I think I think they're just suited for
things there's almost like deep
meditation and then there's like the
beginners meditation and yeah yeah yeah
I'm stuck on day ten by the way you do a
great job narrating it Andy put acum is
quite fantastic on headspace isn't his
voice is perfect yeah it really is it's
very soothing
although sam harris has his new app it's
in it's in beta right now and he's been
spending years on us I'm interested to
see what he does listening to him
interview Michael Pollan and I enjoy
yeah book itself actually okay so if
you're talking you mentioned psilocybin
briefly so Michael Pollan's new book how
to change your mind about the rattle the
history the history of psychedelics it's
actually really interesting in the the
neuroscience behind how they affect the
brain is really interesting and it's
it's got very little to do so they used
to be called psychosomatic switch
basically mimicking psychosis that's
what people thought originally but
actually has very little to do with that
and what it what they what they seem to
do is switch off something called the
default mode Network which is basically
your continuous thought processes ego
all that kind of stuff and that and when
you put people in the MRI to look at
this those parts of the brain since you
just get turned off so people are kind
of shutting down the processes
associated with yeah so ego self
comparison and anxiety all that kind of
stuff and then when it comes back on
when it comes back online if there's
been a therapist involved they sort of
like guided you through it
actually you can you can affect a lot of
those sort of mental health issues by
using this as part of like a therapeutic
process so it's really very interesting
yeah and for those of you were
ill-informed or
uninformed I should say we're talk about
magic mushrooms basically LSD has the
same effect DMT from ayahuasca as a
scimitar has a similar effect they will
have that same effect on on that part of
the brain right right and and the
Michael Pollan talks about you know the
the if you do have some sort of risk in
your family of like schizophrenia or
something then you know just just be
careful with that if you're gonna do it
you should I mean if you're gonna do it
for a for a mental health reason and
there is you know for posttraumatic
stress or some of some other the used it
for alcoholism and all these other
things but it requires a therapeutic
relationship with a therapist who's
there at the time it's a guided process
it's not just you at home on the couch
dropping some acid times I didn't get
that far through the book before I got
bored of it well I mean so I'm like what
am I supposed to do with this
information is it like I can go onto the
internet right now and order this thing
and do it anywhere because you can order
it is illegal unless you're in that
right so what you have to develop a
relationship with some kind of physician
you can prescribe it I think what the
well yes but the humanely it's mainly in
a research setting right is that I think
the the idea is that the book is before
that this is you know LSD has this whole
kind of torrid history particularly in
the US and the book is trying to teach
us that it's maybe not what we thought
it was and it has these effects on the
brain that can be beneficial in the
right setting and is trying to de
demonize right this is a baby boomer
problem though know any young people
younger than 50 years old that have that
demonization of the drug Drizzt well
that's well I mean if it's been for the
rest of us it's been illegal for as long
as we've been alive so yeah I know
that's that's I think that's part the
probable you're right I mean it's the
baby boomers who saw Timothy Leary and
all that kind of stuff with LSD back in
the 70s you know that's that's a big
part of the issue but I think that and
Bing and Michael Pollan is one of those
guys yeah writing he's potentially
rising from the instruction manual on
how to change your mind yeah but also it
seems to be that these may be one of the
big concerns from the pharmaceutical
perspective and I'm not a conspiracy guy
thinks big
trying to you know plot against us but
they do have a profit motive and and it
would make sense to keep those to keep
drugs that are not patentable illegal so
that my patent drugs can continue to
serve people if if there are are ways to
treat depression and the the biggest
thing that was I don't know if the stat
is exactly right but it helped
eighty-five percent of people quit
smoking I for one one dose of psilocybin
not only but then they tried to this is
an interesting part of history so that's
yes in the hands of certain therapists
and scientists right in the right
setting so then when they tried to
repeat those with a more rigorous
control setting and they basically gave
you know gave people the drug and then
lock them in a white room by themselves
and surprisingly those guys didn't react
work very well to that so you so it
requires the right setting and requires
a therapist so that's the thing is in
the right setting apparently you know
and again I don't want to sound like I'm
some big poster child for this I'm just
reading the book and I'm enjoying a sign
I'm enjoying the science in the history
but you know so in that if the setting
is right and the Theret and the therapy
is right then it does seem to have
benefit but you can do it very wrong and
then it can have negative effects yeah
absolutely and so so I think that's
that's the big caveat but there also
seems to be a lot of promising research
here and the thing the same Harris talks
about is there's sort of shortcut toward
meditation right I mean in an
understanding yeah so you can get the
same effect from holotropic breathwork
or meditation or like all of those
things can help you switch off those
same parts of the brain and so you don't
you don't have to be taking drugs to do
it right right
it's just much more rigorous process
right yeah but it is it's totally
possible I think in the sauna sometimes
like when I go back and forth between a
hot sauna and a cold plunge I feel
totally euphoric in a way that way I
suppose I could replicate with with
alcohol or marijuana but this is a more
natural way to do it right so yeah I
just something about what else do we
have here introversion versus
extraversion I don't know why I wrote
that down
but um it's probably a good place to I
mean so that's one thing that that
change for me certainly I was this
back-office programmer that used to get
I mean success for me look like not
making eye contact with people you know
locks away in the back office somewhere
and then I started a business got
married had two kids now decided to pop
cast all this stuff that seems quite
extroverted and it certainly wasn't part
of my character before I went through
this process so I don't know like can
all this stuff change that this seems to
be my experience whether it work for
someone else I'm not quite so sure but
it's interesting to think about the
opposite story actually so I worked in
the corporate world I was essentially a
manage hundreds of people and so I was
around people all day every day from the
time I woke up but get my blackberry and
I'd start responding to emails and I'd
hurry up and go into the office and I'm
around people all day leading and
coaching and meetings and blah blah blah
and customers and I'm just around all
these people all day and I didn't
realize how burned out I was that one of
my favorite novels is a book called
freedom by Jonathan Franzen and there's
a line in there and he talks about the
unquenchable thirst of solitude and and
that resonates so much with me now like
I've set up my life in a way that I do
spend at least 80% of my time alone and
it really fuels me in a way that I
didn't realize I didn't realize like I
wasn't getting that fuel and so I was
just I was a non-optimal version of
myself a hundred percent of the time
because I was always around people and
so those interactions at best were 30 40
% of what they could have been so I
don't know if there's any any data that
you all want to talk about with respect
to introversion or extroversion but
health perspective how many how big
would you or tribe have been how many
people would you've seen on the average
day would it be 40 50
I don't yeah like 40 seems like a more
reasonable number yeah so so but I find
that I'm a much better version of myself
I can be at the 70 80 90 100 % version
of myself when I'm around
fewer people and Ryan and I did a recent
episode talking about the the different
types of relationships our lives and and
he's an excuse the exact opposite
extreme extrovert I've never seen him
alone and and he but he has a lot of
sort of the secondary relationships that
I don't have so we we look at these
these I look at relationships as we have
three different types of relation we
have this sort of primary relationship
that use your closest family and friends
you know you can usually count on one
hand two hands if you're Catholic but
the closest people in your life usually
fits on one hand and then you yeah the
the next layer of the concentric circles
you have these the secondary layer of
friends and and these are like people
you consider close friends and family
extended family people you work right
next to and and I find the extroverts
have a lot more people on that second
the second ring and then you have that
third the the peripheral ring or the the
tertiary relationships the acquaintances
the coworkers the the friends that you
see some of my closest friends
I talked to once or twice a year but
they're the most meaningful
conversations I have in my entire life
likely because we only talk once or
twice a year I go back to Dayton Ohio
three times a year usually and and when
I do that I I find that that though I
sit down with the people that I that are
closest to me and I make time for them
we have these great conversations and
it's like we never left but if I had to
see them every single day I don't think
our interactions would be as meaningful
I think with Ryan they probably would be
though like every every day he would
just find something meaningful out of
but it would drain me so he's probably
just found a better answer to the
question so what do you do yeah I could
imagine being you like people ask you
what do you do well I grind you down
it does man I and I I've I now like I I
don't wanna come off as pretentious I've
tried to think of like just really weird
things that I can say to people till I
get them to go away but I find what I
really want to like rip someone I'm like
what do you mean
by that question like do you mean like
what's my job title how much money do I
earn so you can compare you to me on the
socio-economic ladder yeah and so yeah I
think quite often we do mean like what's
your job title and I think that's just a
dangerous question to ask you to because
then we get rapped with this whole
identity of like this is who I am as a
person I'm the Director of Operations
and you can't pry that from my hands and
then when you do when I get laid off my
life's over because you've just you
didn't lay me off you removed my
identity from me and that happens with
the third BMW it happens with the
veganism it happens with the carnivore
diet what do you do I'm paleo what what
does that mean yeah eight days a week
my back hurts no I am all right well
let's uh let me see here I usually do
something called added value say when we
talk about things that have added value
to our lives recently and since Ryan
isn't here I'm just gonna talk about
your podcast I think you guys do a great
job of taking things that are outside of
the the the the world of just medical
terms and jargon and I'm terrified to
even dip my toe in that water because
it's gonna be too hot or too cold for me
and you distilled down to a way where
it's like explaining how to make a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich and I
feel like it's it's digestible for me
and then that when I know like like I
can digest something then I it often
raises more questions and then I'll go
in a different direction so I'll
encourage people we're listening or
watching this to just check out the
nourish balance thrive podcast and if
you're interesting working with these
guys at all just seeing more about them
just go to nourish balance thrive calm
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well and just so quick
follow-up on right here right now it's a
segment we do we talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalist my
birthday is this week I'm turning 37
years old and I want you all to get me a
birthday gift
legitimately want a birthday gift from
you so I'm from data on that with like
two million things
I think these specific about my about my
gift then thank you so so I'm from
Dayton Ohio and second hungriest city in
the United States for families and West
Dayton which I didn't grow up in West
Dayton but I grew up in Dayton and it's
the overdose capital of America we have
a lot of problems there the opioid
epidemic is serious but there's also
another crisis there so I think the
second largest food desert in the entire
country is West Dayton as there is not a
single grocery store there's a million
people in in the greater Dayton area a
couple hundred thousand in the city
proper and the west side half the city
there is not a single grocery store
since Kroger closed in 2009 and so
there's access to to food if you go to
the local liquor store you can buy
Cheetos but you can't buy nutrients you
can't buy a nutrition there's not a
single grocery store and so Ryan and I
have a really ambitious objective we
want to build helped build a grocery
store food co-op in Dayton Ohio next
year and so we're trying to raise some
money and we've partnered up with there
is a place called the Jim City Market
and they don't exist yet but we're
trying to raise funds for them so we're
going to try and raise a hundred
thousand dollars over the next two
months and Ryan and I are going to
donate a significant chunk of our own
money to try to make this happen but we
need your help so if you'd be willing to
donate thirty seven dollars from my 37th
birthday that would be the best gift you
could give me but it's also gonna help
provide not just food because I think
having food access to food is really
important you all know this but also the
education I I didn't know that for me
like there were certain foods that were
really bad for me I just thought you
know I thought potato well it's a
vegetable I might as well just eat all
of them right potatoes aren't inherently
bad but they're better than Cheetos but
how about kale and an arugula and so
we're also we're gonna provide education
with this place and so providing the
access to food the education about food
so the people can make the right food
choices and have food to feed their
families it's something that we want to
do so we'll put a link in the show notes
we can go to on my birthday June 29th is
my birthday by the way
just go to the minimalists comm slash
Dayton in fact you can do that today
they'll take you right to the page where
you can donate if you donate thirty
seven dollars for our birthday you'll
help help us with with this coop that
we're trying to build if you donate
ninety bucks that will give one family a
lifetime membership to the coop so
that's another way to help or you can
donate however much you want to us we've
done a few things in the past where
people want to donate more than that we
by all means we welcome if you want to
give some money help us feed some people
who I mean
this is I mean it's in our backyard eyes
for the first 31 years of my life and in
Dayton Ohio and I can tell you that we
have a lot of problems there and one is
man there just isn't access to to good
food so hopefully you all will be
willing to help out with that the
minimalists comm slash Dayton for
details also Ryan and I are going on
tour were three cities Birmingham and
Louisville Kentucky and then we'll be in
Nashville Tennessee we're doing talking
about money and minimalism it's called
the simply southern tour and you can
find all the details at our website the
minimalists calm that's July mid July I
think it's a twentieth 22nd and 24th
we're gonna have Chris Hogan and Rachel
Cruz and Anthony O'Neill with us talking
about money and minimalism so bring your
questions with you it's gonna be
different from any other event we've
ever done and I think that's one that
one of the thing on YouTube I've been
doing something called living room
conversations so little everyday in my
living room I just turn on my phone and
I answer one question someone asks a
question and I've gotten some of the
best responses from just these quick
videos impromptu I don't have anything
prepared someone just asked question I
answer one question it's three minutes
five minutes and that's why we start a
video version of the podcast too because
a lot of people are finding value and in
the video creation so if you want to
check those out one question today over
YouTube youtube.com slash the
minimalists alright that's all I have
besides these voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi my name is
Sabrina I'm from Brooklyn and I was just
listening to your podcast about food
one thing I encourage people to do when
they go to the farmers market in order
to save money is to ask the farmers for
a second choice produce
it's the stuff that's a little bit
bruised or it's not quite as pretty and
they usually sell it for a quite a steep
discounts so often times I can get
tomatoes that are originally six dollars
a pound for two dollars a pound so
people are looking to budget or to save
money on food especially organic local
food I encourage you to ask for the less
beautiful produce
this is Joe from Dallas and this was a
comment for some parents who have
trouble with all the things that their
kids have and don't necessarily want to
throw away their children's things
without permission from their children's
they're talking to their kids about it
we had a playroom that was exploding
with toys and what we did was we adapted
the minimalism game for our kids and so
we asked him what motivated them and
they talked about getting new toys so we
decided we were going to let him do it
for a month and for every number that
they got to on their game we would give
them $10 at the end of the month to
spend so the first way they got rid of
they got $10 and then to get to number
two they give away two toys and they'd
be at $20 and then three toys and so
that'd be six total and maybe at 30 just
like the minimalism game but we didn't
go buy days we just let him go as the
months went on I underestimated my
children they each got to 13 toys which
was over ninety and really over a
hundred because they got through they
got rid of some collections of toys like
plastic dinosaur collection would be one
toy and so I owed them two hundred and
sixty dollars to go on a shopping spree
and instead of buying 13 toys each they
they pooled their money and they bought
three toys that they really wanted and
so I traded in 200 toys for three toys
and in one month we really got rid of a
big chunk of that playroom and on a whim
after we went on our shopping spree for
the three items I threw 91 smiley faces
on a napkin to show my daughter and I
said this is how many kids that you made
happy this month and for those that are
worried about consumerism or or teaching
their kids that you know the the reward
for doing well is to go on a shopping
spree when they had a playdate a few
days later and they brought their
friends to their playroom it wasn't the
new toys that they went to they had kept
the napkin and they showed their friends
that you know they were so proud of how
many kids that they had made happy this
month panda we've had it continue to go
for the last couple of months and we
have drastically reduced the amount of
toys that we
have in the house and the kids have toys
that they really really wanted and that
they they were invested in because they
got to choose them themselves I hope
this helps some families out there it's
been very helpful for us
a minimalist my name is Emma calling
from Mammoth Lakes California I recently
listened to your episode on social media
and I had a great tip for people who are
looking to cut back their use of social
media whether it be for time spent using
it or if just the fact that getting
caught up with social media is taken
away from the other things in their life
that are bringing them value one thing I
have done to cut back my use of social
media is gone to my settings of my phone
and turned off cellular use data for
certain apps so for example if I want to
cut back my time spent on Facebook I can
go to my cellular youth area of my
settings and turn off cellular data for
that app meaning I can only access that
app if I'm attacked if I'm connected to
internet and I've done this for most of
my social media app just because it cuts
back how much I use them and allows me
to a save some of my data because I
don't like going over and having to
spend more money but also just not using
that as much as I used to
all right so that's almost it for this
episode I want to thank you both for
being here today
Chris Tommy I this is one of the best
conversation we've ever had in this
podcast mainly because Ryan wasn't here
but you are a wealth of knowledge I'm
grateful to you decided to come in today
and spend this time with me I know folks
will get immense value from this whether
they watched it on YouTube or or they
just listened to the the podcast but I'm
really grateful you decide to spend this
time with us thank you so much likewise
yeah thank you for having us and thank
you for being such a fantastic client
and yeah Tommy he is a wealth of
knowledge and I've not really met anyone
that can integrate all of the things out
there like quite like you can in such an
unbiased way so yeah super glad to be
here and have the opportunity thank you
thank you and if if you'll have a
question for the minimalist give us a
call or a comment for the end of the
episodes four zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo right from your phone
to podcast at the minimalists comm if
you all live here with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time and minimalists
[Laughter]